think back to your childhood and ask
yourself what was the most pain you've
ever felt while growing up as we develop
our understanding of pain evolves
according to our different experiences
the older we get the injuries we
suffered as children like a scraped knee
or a beast sting rarely causes the same
level of distress as they used to of
course when you are young and unfamiliar
with sensations of pain what you really
need in that moment straight after
you've fallen off your bike or tripped
playing soccer is is someone to pick you
back up and give your Source spot a kiss
perhaps you even need a bowl of warm
soup to comfort you luckily for you SCP
348 is exactly that while many of the
anomalies held in containment by the SCP
Foundation have earned the uid or
inFAMOUS ker class designations SCP 348
is one of the few considered to be safe
both in the sense it poses no
containment risk and in that it wouldn't
hurt a fly it is neither an ancient
eldrich Abomination From Another
Dimension spreading its influence in our
world through mimetic stimuli nor is it
a recording of a basketball game in
which all the players and Spectators are
trapped inside it isn't an
indestructible limb generating reptile
or a towering winged being wielding a
flaming sword and guarding the entrance
to the Garden of Eden to put it simply
SCP 348 is a bowl a white ceramic Bowl
the kind you would find almost anywhere
in the world it may even look IND
distinguishable from the one in your
kitchen cabinet of course SCP 348 is
hardly as ordinary as it outwardly
appears to be and it certainly isn't the
only inanimate object that the
foundation keeps safely stored away the
key thing that differentiates SCP 348
from most other anomalies is how
genuinely harmless it is its anomalous
properties do not cause injury to any
individual that interacts with it nor
does this bowl have any adverse effects
on the world around it scp3 48 cannot
bend or reshape reality it does not
cause the person eating from it to have
premonitions of their own death and
using it certainly does not manifest a
contract making entity at the opposite
side of the table so what makes this
bowl in any way anomalous what about it
categorizes it as an SCP and not just a
harmless piece of fine Crockery well why
don't we start with how SCP 348 was
first discovered some time ago the SCP
Foundation was made aware of rumors
surrounding the child living in an
unknown part of the world according to
the intelligence gathered by the
foundation this child seemed to possess
some sort of healing ability or at least
this is what rumors suggested upon
further investigation the source of
these so-called remarkable recovery
abilities wasn't the child but appeared
to come from a small ceramic pole which
we now know as SCP 348 this is not to
say that the bowl has any inherently
Supernatural healing properties and it
doesn't impart any regenerative power to
to those that eat from it either it does
heal in a certain sense but not in the
way you're probably imagining when the
SCP Foundation recovered SCP 348 there
were no markings on it indicating where
the bowl came from or who it was
manufactured by the only visually
distinct details worthy of note were
flowery patterns that appeared to be
hand painted around both the inside and
outside of SCP 348 the ceramic surface
also bore the Chinese letters Shang
shini which translates to the phrase
thinking of you the child that first
discovered it found the ceramic Bowl in
the Attic of their home the child's
parents were both full-time workers and
seemed to be somewhat neglectful of
their child although they refused to
comment on this but according to the
findings of the SCP Foundation the child
had come to rely on SCP 348 deciding to
further investigate the anomalous
properties of SCP 348 the foundation
began testing it given that the child
who first discovered the bull had relied
upon it tests involve Foundation
researchers presenting certain children
to SCP 348 and observing the results so
was this bowl haunted perhaps harboring
some malicious Spirit or entity that
sought to corrupt these children maybe
even healing them in order to somehow
use them as a vessel to break into our
world no and while may have not healed
in any overt or expected way it did heal
in at least a metaphorical sense it
presented with an injured child sporting
any form of minor ailment such as a cut
or a running nose SCP 348 fills with
warm soup and yes that's right we said
soup what kind you may ask well that
seems to vary sometimes it is tomato
soup other times it might be chicken
noodle soup while the ingredients used
in the soups are often different there
are notable consistencies to how SCP 348
heels if anyone between the ages of 4
years old and 18 years old sits down in
front of the blue flowered Bolt then SCP
348 will fill with soup numerous young
test subjects brought in by the
foundation to eat from this particular
bowl of soup have reported that they
enjoyed their meal usually finishing the
entire Bowl when permitted to by
research staff many of the injured
children that were tested have stated
that the soup they eat from SCP 348
reminds them of their parents' cooking
these children have expressed
contentment and feelings of comfort
after acquiring their various cuts and
bruises some even claim that even though
they were in a room all alone they
didn't feel lonely when they were eating
the soup and all the anomalous
properties don't end after a child
finishes the soup usually although not
always the bowl will leave the child a
message often some brief words of
reassurance or Comfort these messages
materialize on the inside rim of the
bowl and seem to be specifically
tailored to the subject that is just
eaten the words will not only be written
in the child's first language but are
often linked to the child's home life or
relationship with their parents messages
that appear on SCP 348 usually fade over
time normally disappearing after a few
hours or when the bowl refills with more
soup one test of SCP 348 saw a little
girl age8 and suffering from a sore
throat brought before the bowl according
to a background screening made by
research Personnel the girl lived with
her biological parents and apparently
had a good relationship with both her
mother and her father when CP 348 filled
with soup for her the girl took almost
half an hour to finish eating and
afterwards reported that she felt her
sore throat get better as she ain't by
the end of the meal this test subject
remarked that she felt completely normal
in this instance no message appeared
within the bowl another child was
brought in to continue the testing of
SCP 348 this time a boy of 10 unlike the
previous test this boy was not on good
terms with his parents and often argued
with them at the time of testing the boy
had sustained several minor bruises the
result of a small accident that occurred
while the boy had been out riding his
bike much like the little girl this
subject ate the soup that SCP 348
presented him with this time though the
bowl offered a message to the boy the
lettering found on the ceramic surface
of SCP 348 simply read don't forget to
brush messages also appeared when an
11-year-old boy with a slight cold ate
soup from the bowl this child had been
adopted by a foster family and after
eating from SCP 348 he saw the message
I'm glad you're happy appear another
young test subject a boy age six had a
similar experience in this instance the
child had several scrapes and scratches
from playing with his friends his
parents had divorced and he was living
with his mother at the time of testing
this time SCP 348 message to this boy
read I'm sorry son a 7-year-old girl
suffering from a cough was brought in
before 4 SCP 348 she had lost her father
to a traffic accident some time before
testing commenced and received the
message I love you after finishing her
soup further testing conducted by the
foundation revealed that anyone over the
age of 18 years who attempted to eat
soup from SCP 348 experienced things
slightly differently unlike the children
older subjects mostly displayed a
disinterest in finishing their meal a
common complaint among those over 18 was
that the soup was missing something
however in a few isolated cases testing
SCP 348 on older candidates still
revealed messages although the words
seemed to be faded not the clear hand
painted blue that appeared when the
children had finished their soup one
woman aged 30 who was suffering from a
headache sat down in front of SCP 348
much like it had done before the bowl
filled with soup and the woman ate as
with some of the younger subjects a key
aspect of This Woman's background seemed
to be what triggered the message to
appear specifically she admitted to
being on bad terms with her mother and
father the woman explained that she had
opted to live on her own isolating
herself from her family in fact she even
described having rejected an offer her
father made to her many years earlier
refusing some Career Training that he
was willing to give in order to help her
secure a job when she finished the soup
one word appeared in the bowl why
another woman who was 40 years old was
also brought in for the SCP 348 test ing
much like the previous subject she had
moved away from home and became arange
from her parents over the years but
unlike the previous test this woman had
taken it upon herself to not only send
money to her parents but also arranged
senior care for both as well prior to
testing her father had died peacefully
of natural causes after spending his
last days in the care that this woman
had paid for as the woman ate the soup
from the bowl she remarked about its
apparently bitter taste but also
described her meal as fulfilling after
she had finished the words thank you
appeared with an SCP 348 one other adult
subject that produced a noticeable
result from SCP 348 was a 40-year-old
male the results of this test appeared
to be the most distinctly different from
any previous adult or Child by now
researchers working for the SCP
Foundation had determined that familial
history seemed to play an important role
in the outcome of any interaction with
SCP 348 and this individual was
certainly different to most the man in
question had murdered his father roughly
a year before the testing took place he
began the test with SCP 348 while
Afflicted with aches in his back after
one Taste of the soup that appeared in
the Bowl before him the murderer was
immediately repulsed he complained about
the taste refusing to eat any more from
SCP 348 shortly after the man began to
experience severe stomach pain the
potentially poisonous soup was disposed
of but SCP 348 immediately filled with
saltwater which took 3 hours to
disappear from the bowl despite
conducting numerous tests with subjects
of all ages and ailments the SCP
Foundation researchers have so far been
unable to determine the origins of the
messages that sometimes appear in SCP
348 some are theorize because of the
family histories of some children and
adults tested that the words somehow
come from the father of whoever eats the
soup since even when a subject's father
is alive or present in their life the
message seems to convey feelings that
their father has or would have other
researchers claim that this is just the
purpose of SCP 348 to provide Comfort to
small children dealing with pain both
inside and out after all isn't providing
Comfort what a good bowl of soup
anomalous or not is best at working at
the SCP Foundation can really get your
appetite going after spending a rough
shift monitoring the levels in SCP 682s
tank or performing the rituals necessary
to keep the devour of worlds on the
other side of SCP
2317 sometimes you just need a quick
snack to hold you over before you return
to the old grind problem is at the SCP
Foundation even the break room can be
perilous Dr Dan is notorious for
pilfering pudding cups from the communal
fridge and ever since the administrator
himself stole your tuna sandwich you
just don't feel safe spending your lunch
break on site anymore but this present
its own series of issues you only have
an hour for lunch and obviously you
can't order in due to security issues
also if you're eating off site you have
even less time to finish your lunch
because the site you're currently
stationed at is relatively remote we're
talking at least a half hour round trip
to actually get to somewhere so you're
going to need your food fast and when it
comes to fast food few eateries are as
prolific as the golden arches McDonald's
and just to clarify this video is not
sponsored we're going to tell you about
a horrify find anomalous secret that
this company really doesn't want you to
know about let's not think about that
just yet though your stomach is rumbling
and you need that quarter pounder so bad
that even being trapped in the red
reality with Dr Scranton couldn't stop
you from getting it when you finally
arrive you buy your typical order a
quarter pounder with french fries a
coffee and a McFlurry you see Dr klef a
few tables down enjoying a box of
chicken nuggets and ketchup but decide
not to engage as you sit and enjoy your
meager little lunch knowing you'll
probably be coordinating the cleaning
efforts of scp1 73's containment chamber
by the end of the day your eyes drift
over to something even more unsettling
happy the current mascot for McDonald's
Happy Meals you can't help but shudder
you've seen some pretty horrific things
on the job nightmarish things you fear
no monster but that thing it scares you
those big soulless eyes the wide gaping
ma full of two white teeth it's diabolic
sneakers no child should ever have to
look at that you can't help but wonder
whatever happened to Ronald McDonald the
hamburger happy clown that Shield fast
food to you throughout your childhood
what is he up to now well we have an
answer for you but I'll warn you you may
not be quite as eager to suck down a Big
Mac and a DI of coke after hearing this
Ronald McDonald first introduced as the
company's mascot in 1963 had a pretty
good run before finally being largely
phased out by the company in the
mid-2010s for a greater focus on the
nasty little box homunculus you can
thank John Wayne gasy Pennywise and
those goofballs dressed up as clowns
back in 2016 for that but like anyone
who loses favor Stateside Ronald had a
prosperous career ahead of him outside
the country well not the Ronald we know
at least you see in an undisclosed
cattle farm in 2004 most likely in North
America a monster was born a horrific
Abomination birth from a cow like many
have theorized about SCP 058 the Heart
of Darkness but this nasty little
creature wasn't a giant heart with a
stinger and Scorpion legs in many ways
it appeared superficially humanoid save
for its stark white skin its thick red
lips and its full head of bright frizzy
red hair but that was only the start of
the unnerving strangeness exhibited by
this miracle child it was born with
white gloves and long clownish shoes
seeming ly grafted to its feet fresh
from birth the creature was huge with a
disportionately large head and wide
disgusting pores that seemed to
perpetually leak fry oil the creature
was unresponsive to any kind of external
stimuli perhaps suggesting it was brain
dead and it remain completely dormant
most of the time while most people would
have screamed run away or called the
police the farmers at this particular
cattle farm decided to let it ride and
see how this whole nightmarish Affair
played out that sense of curiosity and
patience would soon pay off for them
financially it didn't take long for the
creature to grow the bigger it got the
more it looked like a giant mutant
version of McDonald's iconic mascot
Ronald McDonald and this wasn't just a
coincidence either it turned out that
this monster was somehow intrinsically
linked to the McDonald's brand because
once a day the creature would
horrifically unhinge its jaw and begin
to barf out a huge quantity of
McDonald's food and we're not talking
about raw materials that are converted
into McDonald's food the creature later
dubbed SCP
5962 vomited out fully packaged
McDonald's products the owners of this
clownish monster had just hit the
lottery so to speak while the
particulars of the deal are unclear they
somehow contacted a representative of
the McDonald's corporation based in
China in exchange for presumably a large
sum of money Chinese McDonald's
operatives covertly entered the country
and shepherded the now massive creature
over to a McDonald's owned Warehouse in
Beijing by this point it was around 4 M
tall and weighed over 5 tons it was kept
inside a cage and housed at some cost
but soon enough the creature was paying
for itself as we mentioned before the
creature constantly secreted fry oil
which was siphoned off for use in
preparing McDonald's food across the
country the huge quantity of packaged
food that had vomited out every day was
also shipped off to restaurants across
the country making the Chinese branch of
McDonald's incredibly Financial
successful they were able to make an
almost complete profit on all of these
foods and drinks once transport costs
were subtracted of course SCP 5962 had
become McDonald's China's best kept
secret but of course no secret this
Sensational could stay under wraps
forever no matter how much people in the
warehouse were paid or threatened for
their silence if your day job was
siphoning grease off of a giant mutant
clown for the purpose of preparing
McDonald's food across the country
there'd be no way you wouldn't speak to
somebody about it no nobody knows whose
loose lips sunk this incredibly
profitable ship but rumors began to
spread around Beijing about a huge clown
inside of a McDonald's packaging
facility that was when local field
agents of the SCP Foundation finally
took notice two agents Jonathan Jang and
George nagasa were dispatched to perform
an infiltration Mission along with a
team of backup Personnel they entered
the warehouse apprehending any employes
they found as they and their
reinforcements reached the northern side
of the facility they found CP 5962 with
a heavy collar around its neck chained
to the ground like King Kong as
McDonald's employees wielded away carts
of package food neither of the attending
agents were fans of McDonald's food but
even then just seeing this horrible
display was enough to make them feel
nauseous the creature was taken and
contained by the SCP Foundation who
conducted a number of tests on it they
found that the monster had no real
internal organs save for 27
interconnected stomachs genetically they
also found found that the creature was
far more cow than human the same could
sadly not be said for the food that SCP
5962 was vomiting out seriously if you
were already feeling a little queasy
from all this we need to warn you that
this is the part where things get really
vile let's talk about what the
McDonald's food barfed up by SCP 5962
was actually made out of as we mentioned
earlier the food exuded by the creature
was genetically human with DNA often
matching that of people who are alive
and in no way affected by this anomalous
process tests have indicated that
certain foods condiments and beverages
correspond to more specific types of
bodily tissue and liquid for example the
bacon and Fries were shown to be
cartilage and ligaments the bread turned
out to be made from hair nails and skin
the coffee was liquefied feal matter the
chicken nuggets were made from fingers
ovaries and testes even the water was a
mix of saline and sweat and of course
the ice cream was comprised of pus bone
marrow feces and nasal mucus depending
on the flavor you get the idea we'll
stop listing off examples before you
lose your lunch but rest assured all of
the food produced by SCP 5962 was made
of human organic matter when the SCP
Foundation interviewed Mr Chen the
manager of the facility where SCP 5962
was being held before his amnestic
treatment he seemed incredibly casual
about the whole thing as far as he was
concerned the food still tasted exactly
the same as regular McDonald's food and
it didn't appear to have any diverse
health effects beyond what you could
expect from regular non-anomalous fast
food it's actually less cruel and
disturbing than the slaughterhouses
where the meat is typically obtained Mr
Chen also contested that SCP 5962 wasn't
all that dangerous either the only time
it ever performed at offensive action
was when an employee of the enemy fast
food franchise Burger King entered its
vicinity the creature vomited a stream
of hot coffee at the corporate
interloper like a fire hose until he
left suggesting that it does have some
kind of strange inherent loyalty to the
McDonald's company but still other than
this isolated incident the creature has
never even displayed sentience it was a
big strange clownish McDonald's food
dispenser when questioned about the
origins of SCP
5962 Mr Chen once again underplayed the
strangeness of the situation saying that
he'd heard rumors the farm that sold him
SC SCP 5962 had also sold other strange
anomalous creatures to eager buyers in
the US the farm which we can only assume
is situated right next to a radioactive
waste dump was also behind SCP
4158 also known as Big Charlie this
giant omnivorous and seemingly Immortal
mutant cow is believed to have been
birthed from a non-anomalous cow sold to
the Butcher Block slaughterhouse it
looked hideous and seemed to suffer from
a wide variety of health issues leading
to the employees at the slaughterous
trying to put the creature out of its
misery however no matter how hard they
tried to kill the monster it just
wouldn't die its bones were pretty much
indestructible and no matter how much of
its flesh was cut off it just kept
growing back causing no ill effects to
the creature itself eventually The
Slaughterhouse workers tried cooking and
eating the meat leading to them
discovering it tasted just as good as
nonanomalous meat much like the Chinese
McDonald's and SCP
5962 the workers had just hit the
lottery with big Charlie as long as they
kept feeding the monster which ate
everything from bricks to other
non-anomalous cows it provided a pretty
much Limitless supply of meat giving
them unprecedented economic prosperity
in other words big Charlie was a literal
Cash Cow Jeff fine the slaughterhouse
director even started worshiping big
Charlie as a kind of demigod by drinking
his blood he believed that big Charlie
was a savior sent to lift them all out
of their struggle and Desperation sadly
for them the SCP Foundation sent them
right back when big Charlie escaped
their slaughterhouse and found station
field agents found secured and contained
it it was a sad day for the Butcher
Block so what have we learned today
whether you're in the US OFA or the
Chinese Heartland if you're chowing down
on fast food you really have no idea
where it came from I mean we kind of
knew that already but for all we know
the food you're enjoying could have just
been vomited up by a giant fat clown or
cut from the Flesh of a mutated cow just
think about that next time you're
enjoying a burger but hey let's be
honest with ourselves we'll all probably
still eat it you feel the Panic making
your temperature rise like chili oil on
the tongue as you race down an Alleyway
narrowly avoiding the Carnage unfolding
all around you ducking behind a wall you
press your back against the brick hoping
that if you maybe just stay still you'll
avoid getting caught in the crossfire
War has come to the streets of this
small New York town but it is unlike any
conflict you could have ever imagined
the township of ago hasn't just been
turned into a war zone it's a cal Zone
staring at you on the opposite wall of
the alleyway are posters overlapping
posters all of the exact same
advertisements for the ago hot slice
they're everywhere covering the whole
wall with scrawled lettering hand drawn
over each one that reads all hail Kevin
aglo hot slice loves you join us eat eat
eat eat eat come be with us come be with
us we love you it's like a nightmare
that you can't wake up from everything
around you serving up a reminder that
you're in deep dish and any moment now
you'll be dead meat taking a deep breath
to steady yourself you grip your camera
in your trembling fingers removing the
lens cap and holding on tight as you
peer out from the alleyway to snap some
shots of the front lines the world needs
to know about this Mayhem all the lives
lost and marinara spilled in a senseless
exchange of violence the lens brings the
moving shapes down the street into Focus
but you still can't believe that they're
real the soldiers of this War aren't
human not all of them at least you
distinctly remember seeing two human
combatants the leaders of these Waring
factions one of the foot soldiers is
clashing with an enemy a homunculus
almost in the vague shape of a person
facing off against against a metallic
Mass armed with circular blades as your
finger presses the shutter you capture
the closing moments of their Fight The
homunculi Swinging a large formless arm
almost like it's made out of a lump of
clay missing hands and fingers of its
own trying to use brute strength against
its metal opponent the next shot shows
the metallic creature slicing through
the homunculus with deadly practiced
efficiency leaving nothing but a pile of
dough and cheese leaking thick goopy
marinara sauce onto the asphalt you
lower your camera tears streaming down
your face as you look around and see
scenes like that unfolding all around
you they're fighting in every building
on every street corner the Thunder of
artillery strikes and explosions from
crashing drones are deafening war is
hell and now you've seen that for
yourself firsthand but while your
attention is fixated on the horrors of
bread and cheese-based warfare erupting
all around you you don't notice a
hulking Pizza creature lumbering behind
you ready to strike Welcome to aglo New
York Ground Zero in a war unlike any
other a conflict that the SCP Foundation
has designated as SCP
4201 like any War it's important to know
who the key players are what the
inciting incidents were that triggered
it and what deep-seated ideological
differences are being fought over it's a
war between two two pizza restaurants oh
really well that sure seems a little
Half Baked I didn't like that one too
cheesy for
you in that case pop some lactose
tablets and grab a slice of the action
ready to understand exactly how and why
these two rival businesses turn to
enemies duking it out on the battlefield
do you remember the 23rd night of
September because that's when the
municipality of aglo New York welcomed a
brand new eery to its humble Township
their local paper The aglo Herald was on
the scene to report on the grand opening
of the aglo hot slice a new Pizzeria
established by local resident Kevin
Kerber now you might not think that the
opening of a new pizza place would be
all that newsworthy but for one not much
happens in aglo New York and for another
what made this a notable occurrence for
the locals was that the opening of the
aglo hot slide put the fledgling
Pizzeria in the crosshairs of a local
staple Mario's Pizza de
deloso history would come to know the
23rd night of September
1997 as the day the first shot was fired
in a war that would consume alow in
Flames like a wood burning oven for over
35 years Mario bian's traditional
Italian Pizzeria had been a local
fixture a homegrown icon bringing the
people of aglo hand tossed dough that
was Woodfired to Perfection and served
with a smile but smiles turned to sour
scowls as Kevin Kerber opened up the hot
slice many aglo residents feared that
this challenge to Mario's Pizza DEA
deloso would drive business away from
the long-standing local favorite but
there was a division of public opinions
with others glad for the arrival of the
aglo hot slice and the potential a new
Pizzeria had to to break the Monopoly
Mario's had on the localized market for
his own part the founder of the aglo hot
slice Kevin Kerber had no intentions of
musling in on Mr bian's Turf Kevin lived
in aglo for his entire life and had
plenty of fond memories of visiting
mari's to enjoy a slice with his friends
back when he was still in middle school
he was nothing but amicable towards the
local pizzeria owner and viewed the
opening of his hot slice as nothing more
than encouraging some he healthy purely
professional competition between the two
of them it was Kevin's hope that the
competition would encourage both his and
Mario's businesses to maintain a
consistent quality of their food and in
a sense he was right the quality of both
their pizzas would certainly be put to
the test not just on the battlefield of
ago's Pizza Market but on the actual
Battlefield the town would soon become
to begin with there seemed to be little
animosity between Mario and Kevin's
competing pizzerias for both Mario's
Pizza de deloso and aglo hot slice
business was booming while Mario had the
skills in many more years of experience
he was clearly not threatened by the
existence of his new rival yet over his
more than three decades in ago Mario had
consistently put his other competitors
out of business thanks to the quality of
this pizza he even toppled the local
Pizza Hut Outlet so it was clear that he
didn't think there was much cause for
concern when the aglo hot slice opened
its doors Mr bian wasn't one to cower
from his Challenger either he made a
point of trying Kevin Kerber's Pizza
even complimenting it as the best pizza
Mario had ever tasted from a competitor
at least according to Mario in an
interview he gave with the aglo Herold
hot slice had nothing on his own pizza
and even claimed that Kevin would have
to step up his game if he wanted a piece
of the local pizza pie well not exactly
an explosive retaliation by Mario biani
the oven glove had certainly been thrown
down and the war to determine who had
the strongest pizza was on their War
wasn't initially one fought with guns
and bombs but their Primary Weapons in
their earliest battles were pizza and
advertising despite the widespread
Acclaim his pizza was earning Kevin
simply could not contend with the
longevity and positive reputation that
Mario's Pizza DEA delisio so held in
aglo he couldn't help that whenever
residents thought of pizza they
automatically thought of Marios after
all the garlic season veteran had put
five other competitors out of business
snuffing them out for good and leaving
him as the only Pizzeria standing in
aglo but Kevin was determined and
nowhere was that more apparent in his
aggressive marketing campaign for hot
slice the entire town seemed to be
covered in advertisements for Kevin's
Pizzeria touting the quality customers
could expect from eating there this
seemed to be doing the trick as within
its first week ago's hot slice saw
around 7,000 customers impressive
figures when you consider that the
town's population was only around 10,000
it was almost as if the entire town was
mesmerized by Kevin and his pizza one
advertisement featured in The agow
Herald even included the quote it isn't
possible for pizza to be perfect
attributed to some someone who's never
tried aglo hot slice within the first
month of hot slice's opening things
started to take a turn for the strange
although the town of AGA wasn't exactly
known for being a hot bed of extreme
weather the night of October 3rd 1997
would have been seen as unusual anywhere
else a freak thunderstorm rolled into
ago bringing with it a massive downpour
of rain the force of the storm was
actually so great that many locals found
that whole formed in their roofs letting
the water come pouring in but that
wasn't even close to the strangest part
about the storm local meteorologists
estimated that there were over 700
individual strikes of lightning that
night with the two most notable
locations that were affected being
Mario's Pizza DEA deloso and the aglo
hot slice the latter in particular took
a heavy beating during the storm being
struck by approximately 50 light in
bolts however it seemed that Kevin had
been preparing for the weather despite
how unusual it was for the area almost
as if he had been expecting it he'd
installed 20 lightning rods on his
property meaning the damage was kept to
a minimum as were the effects of the
storm on Marios which remained
relatively unscathed although it
certainly seemed as if the heavens
themselves had chosen a side in the
ongoing feud between the Rival pizzerias
the strange happenings didn't stop with
the freak storm either later that same
month a pair of local teenagers
witnessed something that baffled them
both strange humanoid creatures in
Mario's Pizza deail yoso the aglo police
wrote their story off as nothing more
than teenage hooligan likely fueled by
illicit substant use but the two boys
Jeffrey aisel and Justin copper stood by
their story regardless of how
inexplicable it sounded while walking
around Town late one night the two of
them noticed strange movements inside
the pizzeria what first caught their
attention was the lights were still on
well past 11:00 at night whereas Pizza
deloso closes at 9: checking closer the
pair of teenagers tried the front door
only to find much to their surprise that
it was still unlocked stepping inside
Jeffrey and Justin saw Mario biani
sitting at one of the booths in his own
restaurant with pizza slices on the
table before for him he began lighting
candles and placing them around the
table while reciting a strange chant
that the boys found incomprehensible but
they continued to watch as he grounded
up a red chalk-like substance in his
hands then blew the resultant dust over
the pizza slic given what happened next
it's safe to assume he wasn't trying out
a new type of topping before the
terrified and Confused eyes of the two
teens the pizza formed an inhuman
creature it sat up and scanned the room
quickly SP in the pair of intruders
which caused a mouth to form in its head
slice the pizza homunculus screeched at
Jeffrey and Justin causing Mario to get
up and start yelling at them both to
leave 2 Days Later the strange reports
surrounding the Waring pizzerias
continued to circulate with even more
ads for the hot slice plastered all over
town over the course of what appeared to
be a single night every square foot of
space in aglo was plastered with new
advertisements there was no way that
Kevin k Bert acting alone could have
placed that many posters and flyers for
his Pizzeria in a single night to make
things even stranger over 70% of the
local residents had visited the hot
slice since the advertisements were
posted with many of them not coming back
out staff from The aglo Herald attempted
to investigate but similarly didn't
return making it impossible for anyone
to learn what was truly going on inside
then sometime after this it happened
tensions Rose getting hotter like
melting cheese until war broke out SCP
4201 is the designation given to the
ensuing conflict between Mario's Pizza
DEA deloso and the aglo hot slice both
restaurants possess their own military
forces each deploying different weapons
and tactics that seem to be linked to
each different pizzeria's Aesthetics and
theme Mario's troops consisted of large
anomalously animated homuncular like
creatures each one was made out of
various Pizza ingredients including
dough cheese and various other toppings
made to order well to follow orders
these forces were divided into infantry
and Cavalry with their combat style
highly similar to that of the Napoleonic
War era Mario's foot soldiers were all
armed with beded rifles while they were
supported by calary units and artillery
their Commander himself rode into battle
on a construct that resembled a horse
however made out of the same ingredients
as the rest of his forces while leading
his military efforts Mario uses Pizza
based abilities to support his troops
apparently gained through the same
unknown anomalous means that he used to
create his army meanwhile the opposing
forces that serve under Kevin are mainly
drones and robots constructed around
utensils and appliances typically found
in a pizzeria like ovens or pizza
Cutters also acting as the general of
his side Kevin fights in a large suit of
M mechanical armor with several Pizza
themed weapons attached to it he also
utilizes more advanced Battle Tactics
and techniques including deploying his
drones with more modern Firearms as the
two Waring factions Battle For Stuff
crust Supremacy over aglo the SCP
Foundation has established a safe Zone
around the area evacuating any and all
civilians from the area once they
learned of the doughy disaster studying
the ongoing battle they have intercepted
radio communic Cas between Mario and
Kevin that shed light on their reasons
for continuing their Conflict for over
20 years in one recording Kevin lamented
the fact that they'd been fighting so
long and that there was no point in
continuing yet Mario refused to
surrender his rival argued that he
couldn't let the newcomer win and take
all of his customers despite Kevin
pointing out that their customers were
dead killed in the crossfire of the
pizza War the pair descended into an
argument with Mario calling Kevin out
for hypnotizing the town's folk into
eating at the hot slice and then forcing
them to make his metallic Army while
Kevin rebutted citing how Mario murdered
his earlier competitors through the use
of black magic even with everyone in a
10mi radius dead Mario was still
obsessed with defending his Pizzeria he
accused Kevin of never having set foot
in Pizza DEA deloso and that he was
nothing more than a corporate shell with
no care or pride in making Cuisine for
people to this day the Pizza war is
still ongoing and has been raging for
much longer than the advertised 30
minutes or less feeling hungry maybe you
could go for a snack right about now or
a nice refreshing can of your favorite
soda perhaps if you've got some change
burning a hole in your pocket a nearby
vending machine would be a good choice
and trust us there's no vending machine
like this one SCP 261 will give you a
treat that's out of this world or rather
out of this Dimension that's how this
safe class anomaly earned its incredibly
accurate name the interdimensional
vending machine it was first discovered
in a dark alley in Yokohama Japan Japan
is a place where you can find a number
of strange and surprising things and
vending machines but nothing quite like
this the foundation was first alerted to
its presence after one of their web
trollers noticed some interesting
chatter on Japanese online message
boards about a magic vending machine to
these Japanese form users it sounded
like a fanciful urban legend a vending
machine where you could get something
truly Fantastical if you have the yen to
spare but upon thorough investigation
field agents of the SCP Foundation
discovered that the machine was no
Legend and brought it into containment
it's the kind of thing you wouldn't look
twice at an utterly generic black
vending machine with no viewing window
and a handwritten sign in Japanese that
reads out of order but what the vending
machine looks like isn't nearly as
interesting as what it's capable of when
you insert your money into the machine
and it's important to note that it only
accepts Japanese Yen the machine will
dispense some kind of snack food or
drink item however over time the more
the machine is used in a single day the
more bizarre the items it spits out will
become Foundation researchers have
attempted to figure out how the machine
works but their task has been incredibly
difficult so far it doesn't appear to
contain any snack
and it doesn't seem to be made of any
anomalous Parts moreover the machine
simply won't work when the front panel
is opened or when any surveillance
equipment is placed inside in other
words it's pretty much impossible to
look this gift horse in the mouth
strangely the machine is also capable of
working without power though when
unpowered the vended products are likely
to become stranger much faster but let's
be honest here you're not here for
vending machine mechanics 101 you want
to hear about all the weird stuff that
SCP 261 dispenses and frankly we're with
you on that one lucky for all of us this
is one of the anomalies that the
foundation has truly extensive test
records on providing us with a highlight
reel of some of the strangest wildest
and downright most interesting snacks
and drinks straight out of another
dimension bone Appetit let's start off
nice and easy with some of the snacks
and drinks that are not only edible but
also sound like they'd actually be
pretty tasty like Pepsi Dragon twist a
bottle of Pepsi soda with English
packaging that tastes like dragon fruit
Pepsi Co does not produce such a product
but honestly we wish they did same for
Dark Side Cola a clear liquid that
becomes jet black shortly after being
opened which apparently tastes like your
average can of coke with A Touch of
Spice thrown in but hey not everybody
likes Cola maybe you're a Maverick a
rebel only a soft drink with a formal
title can quench your thirst and as such
you prefer Dr pepper in which case maybe
the vending machine will furnish you
with an interdimensional Japanese
product known as Dr Pepper's amusing
straw this spatial anomaly wrapped
inside a Whimsical Dr Pepper branded
straw seems to contain far more liquid
than should be able to fit in the straw
about one bottle's worth of soda to be
precise a nice and convenient solution
for whenever you need to get the fix
that only an accredited doctor of
popology can provide and if you fancy
something from the more in intoxicating
end of the beverage Spectrum for 600 Yen
you can get yourself a rare bottle of
Billy beer it's just the thing for those
who weren't alive during the Carter
Administration but still want to try
brew that was endorsed by the younger
brother of President Jimmy Carter this
anomalous bottle of Suds which was
bottled in the 1970s according to its
label came with a note reading I had
this beer brewed just for me I think
it's the best I've ever tasted and I've
tasted a lot I think you'd like it too
Billy Carter drinking the beer got a DE
class intoxicated for 72 hours but what
if you've just wet your whistle and
worked up a hunger in the process
thankfully SCP 261 has some delicious
interdimensional food to satisfy your
Cravings so for starters how about a
tube of the little Bakery 7 grain this
small aluminum tube lets you squeeze out
a blob of dough which instantly Rises
and Cooks itself into a tasty little
loaf of bread testing is indicated that
the bread is a little chewy but still
tastes completely fine not bad for a
tubed baked good how about some seafood
to go with that bread then maybe for
your entree you can crack open a
delicious pack of lemon clams and we do
mean crack very literally here if you
crack this bag of anomalous clams like a
glow stick they boil themselves and once
you open them you're ready to enjoy a
serving of tasty clams that have a
slight lemon flavoring to them delicious
but if you're not that hungry and just
feeling more like a snack than a full
fancy dinner the machine ma once put out
the Lays blooming onion while it appears
to be a normal onion each layer of the
onion is a different flavor of Chip
leading all the way into the middle
truly a gourmet snack with more layers
than well actually exactly as many
layers as an onion and what about for
those who are anomalously trapped in the
year 2012 and are looking for a snack
that is both tasty and mem worthy well
you'd be lucky to receive a 700 Yen
bacon shirt it's exactly what it says on
the can an edible shirt that both smells
and tastes like bacon and has no real
side effects other than making you smell
a little like bacon while you're wearing
it though this could be a dangerous
anomalous effect if you decide to walk
through your local dog park while you're
wearing it we've been told it pairs well
with the meat hat Teriyaki Fedora a size
64 tril style Fedora made entirely out
of Teriyaki flavored beef jerky the
object came flattened in a cardboard box
bearing the tagline you can have your
hat and eat need it too which is a pun
that probably makes a lot more sense in
their Dimension still a bit hungry well
lucky for you this magical vending
machine has got you covered on dessert
too for 700 Yen the foundation was given
an entire edible chest set with each of
the ornate pieces carve from what seemed
like hard Pez Style candy it's less
checkm and more check eight another pun
that I promise is funnier in another
dimension and for 300 Yen extra you
might walk away with a candy robot
playset these are more hard candy
components that can be put together to
create functional anomalous mini robots
that move on their own walking aimlessly
and bumping into walls but what about
the full meal craving consumer on the go
who wants both a dinner and a dessert
combined into one disgusting package
don't worry the interdimensional vending
machine has got you covered just 400 Yen
can net you some delicious turo chaken
these are balls of fried turkey filled
with chocolate a smaller ball of duck
more chocolate and in the very center a
small ball of fried chicken even the
labeling on the product describes it as
having 450% of an adult human's daily
recommended fat intake we'll leave it to
you to decide if this is a decadent
treat worthy of the gods or utterly
disgusting maybe you're feeling a little
cheeky though or you need the perfect
comedic dessert for your bachelorette
party the vending machine has a candy
direct from an alternate Korea a tasty
if slightly too sweet chocolate candy
shaped like a certain male organ filled
with we kid you not liquid white
chocolate perfect for anyone who has
both the sweet tooth and the sense of
humor of a 12-year-old okay these were
definitely all weird Treats but let's
get really really strange now from the
disgusting to the confusing to the
inedible to the straight up deadly if
you're a bit of a stist perhaps you're
the kind of person who enjoys watching
their snacks dying in front of them
before they eat them for that the
vending machine provides an aluminum box
with a viewing window and a red button
on top inside are a collection of small
furry creatures each with a single big
eye when the button is pressed the
creatures inside are abruptly
superheated cooking them all to death at
that point the Box opens and the
creatures are ready to eat we've been
told they were crunchy spicy and tasted
a little like beef maybe you're part of
the slow food movement for that we
recommend the delicious pile of slugs
which is exactly what it sounds like
this is a produce box like the kind used
for packing strawberries except it's
full of live slugs there are both
advantages and disadvantages to actually
eating these slugs the advantage is that
they contain large amounts of vitamin C
E and most of the B complex which are
all crucial to a healthy and balanced
diet the disadvantage is that they
contain large amounts of arsenic which
will kill you though of course if you
still have a candy flavored death wish
but you prefer your entomological treats
a little more leggy then may we interest
you in a fine caramelized spider for a
modest 500 yen it's full of deadly
quantities of an unknown anomalous Venom
that's pretty much impossible to cure
but it's worth it for the Sweet Sticky
goodness that comes before death sets in
another strange item dispensed by the
vending machine was a tall metal
aluminum canister with a ring pole that
upon opening had a violent chemical
reaction with the air and triggered a
large explosion apparently this
particular beverage was never intended
for oxygenated environments the blast
killed two researchers and resulted in
the temporary suspension of testing
though in a slight silver lining for
this Fiasco the testing area did smell
of citrus for a few days which the
janitors must have enjoyed as they
cleaned up all the body parts another
dangerous snack provided by the vending
machine was a long long tube of chips
called prangles not to be confused with
any other long Tu Bas chips you may be
thinking of when the tube was opened or
popped as they say the declass that the
chips were presented to began
compulsively eating them when
researchers ordered the d-class to stop
it seemed almost as if they couldn't
regardless of the orders given to them
the d-class just kept eating even when
guards terminated the d-class there and
then the corpse continued to eat chips
out of the tube until it was physically
pried out of their hands but if all
those salty Pringles had really worked
up a thirst in you perhaps you can wash
them down with a delicious can of cherry
balm an intense cherry flavored drink
dispensed by SCP 261 for 450 Yen when a
declass sampled this delicious soda they
commented on it tasting strongly of
cherry a few moments later their head
exploded with the force of a stick of
dynamite coating everyone and everything
around it in goo head visera the
resulting cleanup took an arduous 6
hours but wow was that cherry tasty and
finally why not complete this anomalous
vending machine Feast with a 1,000 yen
papier-mâché pinata resembling a dead
horse that comes ready to use with a
baseball bat everyone who saw the piñata
fell compelled to beat it mercilessly
with the bat until candy began to fall
out many in attendance claimed that it
was the 1,000th gift Unleashed by SCP 26
1 and thus warranted celebration once
the dead horse was thoroughly beaten all
Cognito hazardous properties ceased
there's a joke somewhere in there but
for the life of us we're not sure we can
find it oh well maybe it's in another
dimension for a moment we want you to
cast your mind back to your childhood a
time when you weren't as busy or
burdened with the pressures of life that
come as you grow up when you were
carefree and had your whole life ahead
of you nothing but potential and
opportunity a simpler time when the
highest award you could achieve wasn't a
grade or a promotion but something as
simple as your mom or dad pinning a
drawing you did to the door of the
refrigerator oh to be a kid again right
then again maybe returning to younger
days is better left as a fantasy it's
hard to imagine that something so pure
so simple and wholesome as a drawing on
the fridge could ever be something dark
horrific even but then you learn about
SCP 683 and all of a sudden returning to
your childhood becomes something you
hope never happens SCP 683 is an anomaly
with various parts to it so we'll start
with SCP
683-1331 for everyone else picture the
refrigerator that Indiana Jones hid
inside to miraculously survive a nuclear
blast in Kingdom of the Crystal Skull
that was such a plot device I don't know
about you guys but I'm feeling nervous
already like we said at first glance
you'd struggled to spot anything out of
the ordinary about this particular
fridge apart from maybe some slight wear
and tear on the Outside Inside though
it's perfectly clean kept in perfect
working condition for keeping food cool
but that's the first weird thing about
SCP
683-1600 one's anomalous properties the
next is the fact that the power cord of
this refrigerator ends with a plug that
doesn't match any known type of wall
outlet seems even stranger after all who
would design a fridge that can't even be
plugged in right in fact the SCP
Foundation had to design their very own
completely one-of-a kind adapter to
connect SCP 6831 to an ordinary
gas-powered home generator once plugged
in though SCP 6831 functions exactly
like you would expect any other
refrigerator to sort of it's about time
we move on to SCP 683 second component
designated as SCP
subject of this child's drawing is
pretty mundane just some scribbles of a
pleasant mountainous landscape a house a
well a dog a figure wearing a chef's TK
and of course an anthropomorphic son
with a smiley face now sure that might
not sound all that impressive but we
would advise you not to say anything
like that out loud criticizing the
drawing is a comment you might wish you
hadn't made just like when you fill our
comment sections with dated Among Us
memes seriously it's getting old any
person that makes any kind of negative
or disparaging remark about the SCP
683-2382 as their organs and skin are
melted down the amount the person loses
is equal to the mass of food they've
eaten with each bite they will lose more
and more of their body the painful
process will not stop until they have
ingested 42 kg of food making this even
worse the process doesn't seem to Target
any organs that would kill the subject
immediately they're made to suffer an
excruciating pain punished with torture
for daring to try and remove the drawing
from the fridge any and all subjects
will die within 26 days of taking that
final bite and thus losing the last
piece of themselves but where do the
body parts of these people go surely
they don't disappear you must be
thinking and you would be right in
instances like this the third mystery
component of SCP 683 is revealed
referred to as SCP 683 D3 a brown paper
lunch bag will manifest inside the SCP
6831 fridge containing a grim and
grizzly assortment of meals on every
occasion the bag contains a sandwich
with a pretty disgusting filling the
Flesh and viscera of the last person who
dared to criticize the drawing on the
refrigerator there is also a plastic
Ziploc bag in which you'll find the
other half of the stolen organs and
flesh of this unlucky person along with
three chocolate chip cookies
surprisingly these are actually
completely normal cookies with no traces
of DNA or other abnormalities to them
every time there is also one final item
that forms the contents of SCP
6833 and that's a note which reads be a
good boy today this note Bears the same
handwriting as appears on the outer
surface of the paper bag upon which a
single name is written Eric now for
those of you in the know about the
various anomalies of the SCP Foundation
that particular unassuming name name
might sound very familiar it was the
same name mentioned by another anomaly
known as SCP
066 a brief bit of context for you SCP
066 was a living ball of yarn that
displayed friendly Behavior towards
Foundation staff however during an
experiment a thread was cut from SCP 066
his body this caused the yarn to
transform into a ball of meat with a
pair of functional eyes protruding from
it SC SCP 066 became hostile constantly
asking for an Eric whenever someone gets
too close to it the same name Eric was
also found carved into the back of scp1
168 another anomaly encountered by the
SCP Foundation scp1 168 was an anomalous
calculator which actually possessed some
level of sentience and had the ability
to communicate so who is Eric well
theories range far and wide but there's
no real definitive answer as to exactly
who or what Eric might be some claim
he's a reality bending entity others
posit he's an SCP that the foundation
just doesn't know about yet regardless
he's connected to some intriguing
entities a sentient calculator a
formerly friendly ball of yarn and a
fridge with a child's drawing on it that
can steal people's organs and put them
in a lunch bag especially for him it
would seem that Eric is a child maybe a
school boy possibly even the one
responsible for the drawing on SCP 68 3
this child could even potentially be
anomalous in nature of course this is
all just rampant speculation on our part
so it's probably best to take all of
that with a grain of salt as we've said
before it is just a theory n SCP
explained Theory Eric might just remain
one of the foundation's many unanswered
mysteries for years to come but if that
answer doesn't satisfy you then why
don't we go back to SCP 683 maybe
something something in the frid's origin
will give us a further clue to the
mystery of who Eric is the fridge was
first discovered by the SCP Foundation
in the storage unit of a Washington Home
owned by a woman named Yolanda as
coincidence would have it Yolanda was a
collector of vintage Home Furnishings
including refrigerators which would
probably explain why she didn't think to
throw out such an old model of fridge
from the
1950s according to her she found SCP 683
simply left on a nearby street corner
with nobody around that could have left
it there or anyone that could have
possibly been transporting it to the
local dump to give her a hand moving the
fridge Yolanda Enlisted the help of her
nephew who agreed to step in and assist
her in getting SCP 683 back to her house
unfortunately though the nephew passed
away only 2 weeks later apparently due
to Medical complications that came as
the result of a hernia according to his
death certificate could Yolanda's nephew
have been the mysterious and elusive of
Eric could something have happened to
him after his death that allowed him to
become some kind of anomaly who's to say
we can only guess and hope that one day
we might get a full answer as to why
Yolanda never suffered the effects of
SCP 683 she never actually tried to take
the SCP
reminded her of her nephew it would have
been a futile and foolish idea for
Yolanda to have even tried to remove the
drawing at any rate as any who try will
suffer that painful and horrifying
process of losing their organs and
having them appear in Eric's paper lunch
bag even fire can't remove the drawing
from the fridge at least not permanently
suggesting that even the paper it is
drawn on has its own anomalous
properties on three separate occasions
the SCP Foundation has a tempted to test
this setting SCP
683-2400 SCP
[Music]
3 a similar thing happens if multiple
people attempt to remove SCP
683-2382 suffer an anomalous lack of
organs when they next eat something so
you must be thinking that the way to
avoid that is to simply not eat to fast
and not ingest a single meal and yes
you'd be right that does saave off the
anomalous effects of the fridge and the
drawing but also means you're heading
towards an even slower painful death
from starvation to date two different
Foundation test subjects have died this
way by refusing to eat after interacting
with SCP 683 true the SCP Foundation is
most likely sitting on a whole calvacade
of different anomalies that can keep a
person alive without the need for food
but you know what they're like right the
foundation's hardly likely to share the
keys to surviving without having to eat
and there you have it folks that's SCP
683 don't worry it's highly unlikely
that you'll ever encounter it the
foundation keeps it under lock and key
in a Cell fitted with a steel door and
reinforced hinges SC DP 683 remains
covered in a large cloth to prevent any
members of personnel from looking at it
when the fridge isn't being used for
research or experiments but you have to
wonder what if it's not the only fridge
with these anomalous properties after
all it's rare for a manufacturer to make
just a single refrigerator of a certain
model maybe you'd better be wearing next
time you visit someone with an older
model of fridge in their kitchen and
just to be safe if there is a drawing
pin to the front door leave it where it
is an SCP Foundation researcher sits at
a table inside of a standard containment
cell these are often dangerous places to
be especially when the SCP you're
supposed to be studying is one that you
can't see the researcher is taking notes
unsure of exactly what is going to
happen next he can hear the sounds of
knives scraping behind of Flesh sizzling
and Searing from high heat he braces
himself self as a burst of heat hits the
back of his head as if a fireball has
erupted an object floats through the air
and settles in front of him on the table
it's a plate of food and it looks
delicious it may surprise you to learn
that there is no rule that the SCP
Foundation must deal exclusively with
violent and vicious creatures not every
SCP held in containment shares the same
malevolence and contempt for Humanity as
SCP
682 or the world-ending threat posed by
the likes of SCP
2317 some perhaps not many but some are
benign and might even seem outwardly
friendly but you'd still be taking a
huge risk to assume that anything
contained by the SCP Foundation is
completely harmless such is the case
with SCP 5031 as per the foundation's
containment procedures this quasi
humanoid meaning it appears to have some
vaguely human features is held in an
airtight cell that is regularly check
checked by Foundation Personnel on a
bi-weekly basis SCP 55031 has no need
for regular nutrition or regular
interactions from staff the trick with
SCP 55031 is not being eaten by it since
though it doesn't need food it does
still hunt and consume anything it
encounters human or
otherwise avoiding being eaten is hard
enough with creatures that can actually
be seen But like so many other creatures
the foundation keeps contained
SCP 55031 has developed an almost
perfect defense mechanism which is when
observed it will literally cease to
exist some might choose to refer to this
as a Quantum lock however it is worth
noting that traces left by SCP 531 still
remain observable when the creature has
temporarily disappeared for example
Trails of blood and scratch marks left
behind by SCP 5031 still exist when the
SCP itself does
not naturally this makes both avoiding
the creature and capturing it using
cameras difficult however when SCP 531s
existence ceases it still casts a shadow
from this researchers have been able to
determine several of the creatures
physical traits based on its silhouette
it has been deduced that SCP 5031
levitates about half a meter above
ground level Sports an abnormally small
necklace head a top and elongated torso
approximately 1.9 M long with three sets
of spinley lower arms that Branch
outwards using these arms and its
Loosely hanging body SCP 531 will lower
itself to hunt any human or animal that
draws near to it and uses the bladel
likee tail to cut up
food perhaps the most interesting facet
of SCP 55031 Beyond its defensive
capabilities and apparent physical
attributes are the series of nine tests
conducted by senior researcher Stanley
huxel appalled by the condition that the
creature was being kept in hux took over
the role of HCL supervisor for SCP 5031
having grown increasingly frustrated and
empathetic towards the creature
listening to its screams from inside its
iron containment unit huxel devised a
series of tests to introduce SCP 55031
to various different stimuli as a way to
better understand the creature and
hopefully keep it contained in a way
that didn't seem to cause so much
suffering it's worth remembering that
the SCP Foundation makes its to be cold
not cruel in performing their duties to
protect normality and many of the
researchers and staff are just as
capable of having empathy for creatures
as you might for a stray animal at a
shelter the first of huxtable's tests
involved installing speakers an SCP 5031
cell through which a variety of
different ambient and popular pieces of
music were played to see if they had any
effect on reducing the creature's stress
by judging SCP 55031 stress levels based
on how much it screamed when compared to
normal huxel was able to determine how
to best use music to calm the creature
SCP 531 seemed to convey higher levels
of stress when listening to morning
Forest deep Grotto and seaside Paradise
ambients as well as the best of late 60s
British rock band Jeth rotol however the
best of Mozart Ena kiss and Ben Folds
produced dramatically different results
decreasing SCP 5 31's apparent stress
following this test senior researcher Hu
compiled a playlist featuring SCP 531
favorite music over time the stress
reducing effects of Music on SCP 531
seemed to decrease but keeping the
playlist on shuffle seemed to keep the
creature consistently calmer than it had
been
previously the next test involved
introducing inanimate objects into SCP
5031 enclosure to monitor its reactions
and how its stress levels were affected
when a softball was thrown into the
enclosure SCP 531 immediately medely
sliced the ball in two with its tail in
one swift motion a similar result
occurred when researchers threw the
creature a basketball which was quickly
punctured and sliced open by SCP 50 31's
tail its stress levels first seemed to
diminish when the creature was offered a
bowling ball which it rolled around the
enclosure and then later knocked it
against a second bowling ball however
when one of the balls chipped rendering
it unable to roll properly SCP 55031
stress increased dramatically until a
placement was offered researcher huxel
noted that SCP 5031 seemed to possess a
similar level of motor skills to an
average human toddler with similarly
explosive emotional reactions to
match next when given the choice between
two food sources at opposite ends of its
enclosure SCP 531 seemed to gravitate
towards higher quality food most notably
favored cooked rotisserie chickens over
animal carcasses it even chose this
option over a live chicken using its
tail to cut its food into more
manageable bite-sized portions rather
than ripping its meat with its hands or
teeth like many of its fellow
scps researcher huxel recorded these
findings and highlighted that even
though SCP 5031 didn't need to eat in
order to survive providing the creature
with food of a better quality marginally
reduced its
stress senior researcher huxel next
attempted to test SCP 531s coexistence
with other living
subjects each time making sure that the
creature had been adequately fed to
avoid any unseemly
incidents first a live chicken was
introduced SCP 55031 rolled its bowling
ball at high speed towards the chicken
increasing both its and the chicken's
stress levels and inadvertently killing
the chicken in the
process when a second chicken was
introduced SCP 5031 gently rolled a
basketball towards it but ceased any
further engagement after the chicken
squawked from being hit by the ball next
to be introduced in into the enclosure
was a blindfolded d-class staff member
who was instructed to sit down and roll
the basketball towards SCP 5031 after
doing so for several minutes the
creature began to approach the d-class
subject who was instructed to remove
their blindfold to Cease the creatures
existence and prevent any potentially
deadly incidents finally researcher
huxel had another class D engage in a
game of catch with SCP 5031 while facing
away from the
creature this test proceeded
successfully and Senior researcher huxel
remarked how SCP 55031 motor skills were
improving albeit gradually and with some
gentle encouragement through hux's tests
the creature was
learning the next test focused on
teaching SCP 531 linguistic symbols
utilized LCD displays and buttons
connected to a food dispenser One
display showed an image of a rock and
the other an image of a rotisserie
chicken after some brief probing SCP 531
was quickly able to understand that
pressing the button under the correct
display would dispense a rotisserie
chicken for it to eat the creature was
later able to adapt when the following
day the screen displays and materials
dispensed were swapped and then later
set to swap at random intervals when
additional Rock dispensing stations were
introduced this time displaying the word
rock as opposed to an image SCP 531 was
able to determine which station dispense
chicken through a process of elimination
whenever the functions and displays were
swapped SC p531 would find whichever
displayed the word chicken to receive
its food the Final Phase of this test
presented SCP 531 with a single station
displaying the word chicken but with a
button that would remain inactive unless
the creature spelled out the same word
with a collection of lettered blocks it
was provided with after some initial
confusion and frustrations as to why the
button would not dispense food when
pressed SCP 5031 was able to assemble
the word correctly not only activ ating
the button and dispensing food but
proving to researcher huxel that the
creature was capable of learning
language huxel continued to test the
creature encouraging it to spell words
using lettered blocks as a method of
communicating by increasing SCP 50 31's
vocabulary and the amount of human
interaction it received senior
researcher huxel observed that SCP 531
was gradually learning to sing albeit
nonverbally as well as to juggle with
its six hands and was even communicating
its food preferences and Dish
pairings later another class D D 52125
was introduced to SCP 531s enclosure to
Aid in further testing through d521 25's
instructions the creature quickly
learned to draw using crayons and
created artworks depicting itself its
Newfound friend d521 125 researcher
Huxtable a cat and a rotisserie
chicken SCP 5031 new creative site
didn't stop there though as the creature
quickly learned to play chopsticks in
only 2 days once a piano was introduced
into the enclosure SCP 5031 even managed
to start creating its own original
admittedly crude
compositions next a spice rack was
placed inside the creature cell and D
52125 demonstrated how to season meat
this proved to be SCP 531s new favorite
hobby as it spent the next 3 days
experimenting with different
combinations of foods and es using
its letter blocks to request more more
more garlic powder interestingly the
creature only created artwork or music
when D 52125 was present but seemed to
thoroughly enjoy its experimentation
with food when left alone following this
development senior researcher huxel
devised a new test for SCP 531 providing
the creature with cooking utensils and
using D 52125 to demonstrate 5031 was
shown how to prepare a variety of
different dishes from hamburgers and
Tacos to Mongolian beef steak clam
chowder and perals in addition to a
small peanut allergy this eighth test
revealed SCP 55031 to be a phenomenal
Chef possessing culinary skills far
beyond the average person the creature
quickly and enthusiastically embraced
its Newfound talents concocting its very
own brand new recipes with d 52125 even
volunteering to be the first to taste
test 31's dishes it was shortly after
this test that SCP 531 spoke its very
first word and it should come as no
surprise that the word was salt
naturally senior researcher huxel was
very proud of the progress the creature
had made with its development the final
test almost seemed to be what the
creature was born for over the course of
2 months SCP 5031 was tasked with
creating a full three course meal which
would then be served to Foundation staff
for Thanksgiving SCP 55031 not only Rose
to the task but exceeded all of
researcher huxtable's expectations
creating a meal that even Gordon Ramsay
would be hard pressed to find fault with
the creature created a first course
consisting of sweet potato miso soup
seasoned with turmeric next came a
beautiful duck Ki blazed luxuriously
with apple cider and topped generously
with sweet cranberry compost paired with
a sight of butternut squash nooki and
served on a bed of kalees seasoned with
truffle salt the grand finale of the
Exquisite meal was a spiced cassava pie
for dessert complemented with the finest
French vanilla ice cream and a maple
hazelnut syrup and SCP 55031 didn't stop
there the creature also debuted one of
its original musical compositions to
complement the decadent meal it had
created as the staff enjoyed the food
SCP 5031 performed live from its
enclosure the deeply moving piano
concerto for six hands to an
overwhelmingly positive response from
not only senior researcher huxel but the
entire Foundation staff as a fitting end
to the creature's tail huxel reported
that during the Thanksgiving banquet it
had created SCP 5031 stress levels
reduced
entirely new Kinder containment measures
that would keep 5031 safer but also far
more contented were submitted for
approval perhaps some of you may find it
refreshing to learn that SCP 5031 isn't
simply just another malicious malevolent
monster that the foundation has to keep
under lock and key for the safety of the
world instead SCP 55031 is a gentle if a
little frightening at first creature
that just requires careful and
considered guidance instead of a cold
iron cage and aroundthe clock arm guards
through testing senior researchers
Stanley huxel and his fellow Foundation
staff were not only able to help the
creature develop but also found what
makes it tick and not just for the
purposes of containing it instead it is
hoped that SCP 531s creativity and flare
for culinary and musical masterpieces
can continue to thrive and grow under
the proud watch of researcher huxel
being a video archivist for the SCP
Foundation is one of the easiest jobs in
the entire organization you're
responsible for viewing every tape found
in the field every interview with an
anomaly and every event log recorded by
a mobile Task Force if something passes
is your desk that means the foundation's
going to want its contents viewed
transcribed and the original Source
footage stored for preservation compared
to the doctors working tirelessly to
push their research to the boundaries of
understood science and field agents
risking their lives elsewhere your job
of lounging in an airconditioned room
sitting at a computer and watching
videos all day seems pretty appealing at
least on paper it does when you take
into account just what it is you'll be
trans inscribing the Grim realities
present in all Foundation careers starts
to emerge in your deceptively cushy
office gig it's no secret that the
foundation's visual logs describe
unspeakable Horrors within disgusting
body alterations gory details and
terrifying imagery are Mainstays of
foundation files most are never
conscious of the fact that every log
that's been written out had to have been
viewed by someone in the first place
those blank redacted areas where your
imagination has to fill in the details
somewhere someone in the foundation had
to describe that sensitive information
in the first place that Gruesome Kill in
the task force report the visual
archivist saw the footage before they
wrote it out sure your job might be to
watch the foundation's home movies all
day but due to the sheer amount of
visual materials the foundation needs to
transcribe and catalog you'll be on
average seeing far more Horrors than the
typical researcher or Task Force member
instead of being a assigned to one or
two projects at a time you'll witness an
infinite slew of footage from across the
foundation's history you'll just be
viewing all of the horror from a
distance behind a screen after the fact
but you don't need to be told that
you're a professional hardboiled
grizzled veteran of the foundation you
watch hours of footage a day transcribe
it archive it and send it out to be
inserted in the various articles and
files in the foundation database you've
lived through countless Task Force
missions observed endless testing logs
and seen everything from unimaginable
entities to the bloodiest events ever
taken place it used to keep you up at
night but at this point you're
desensitized to almost anything the
world can throw at you maybe that's why
you were the foundation's latest choice
to transcribe the footage recovered from
the site of SCP
6670 you'd heard the stories a series of
tapes the other archists were flat out
refusing in to transcribe due to sheer
disgust and horror they'd been passed
down the line two or three times and now
they came to you in a box of literal VHS
tapes labeled with a strip of tape that
read SCP 6670 recovered media you didn't
doubt that whatever was on these was
intense since it was enough to get a few
Foundation archivists to pass something
that rarely happens but you were sure
they weren't anything you couldn't
handle you inspect the box for a
manifest paper to see if you can gain
any other information about the takes
most of the time the varying parts of
the foundation's research is kept
heavily IND discernible from one another
the right hand never knows what the left
is doing so getting any further context
to the footage you're about to review is
often times necessary but the paper
inserted on top of the box doesn't
reveal much it reads footage recovered
from the discovery site of SCP
6670 containment site 886 Detroit
Michigan that's about as much as you're
going to get but at least it's something
you take the tape that says first on it
and pop it into the VCR yeah you had to
dust off that old dinosaur just for this
the real anomaly is that it still works
after all these years the first tape is
overlaid with a title that takes up the
entirety of the screen happy birthday
Gemma 1988 it reads the camera pans to a
small infant laying down on a cushion
you can tell from the brief glimpses of
the background that the house is
dilapidated poorly held together not the
conditions a child should be raised in
but an unfortunate reality that some
face the baby stares at the camera
wiggling and making adorable baby noises
you wonder if this is Gemma the birthday
girl herself your thoughts are confirmed
by the camera holder who plays with and
tickles Gemma celebrating her birthday
the camera holder asked the baby to
smile for mommy which the little Gemma
gleefully does of course the one holding
the camera is gemma's Mother and the two
are celebrating her first birthday the
rest of the tape is ordinary with Gemma
and her mother playing and laughing
together her mother sings Happy Birthday
to her and the recording stops well that
wasn't so bad you think to yourself in
fact taking into account most of the
stuff that passes your desk that was
pretty good but that was only the First
Take you're intrinsically drawn to the
next one wondering how this could
possibly Inspire so much fear in the
others who watched it second tape The
Shot opens up with a woman dressed in a
slightly tattered sewn together formal
attire she's filming herself standing
before a mirror the title reads job
interview practice tape after the title
disappears she begins talking to herself
she reveals her name Melanie Jamie G
Parker and acts as if she's applying to
a job specifically Ally to an internship
at the Walter media broadcast company
you can tell from the sound of her voice
that this is gemma's Mother Melanie's
mock interview proceeds slowly she's
visibly apprehensive chokes over her
words and seems to be in great distress
melany mentions that she turned 18 the
other day and that she's interested in
applying for a job as a news reporter
still she can't get the words out
properly stuttering and hesitating she's
clearly distracted by something off
camera
Midway through her rehearsal the sound
of high-pitched crying is heard it's the
baby Melanie assures Gemma that she's
coming and leans over to hit the button
to stop the recording before rushing off
to calm down the crying child again
nothing horrible you think it's
difficult to watch someone so young
struggle with the challenges of
motherhood but it hasn't made you lose
your lunch or anything you take out the
third tape pop it in and see what
happens next another title A letter to
my family cut this seems like it was
intended to be thrown out the picture
comes in showing a crying Melanie
sitting on the edge of her bed in a
white gown sniffling up her tears
Melanie delivers a message intended to
be viewed by her family you learn that
her relationship with them is unstable
and that Melanie has been on her own for
months potentially longer she musters
out an apology to her parents saying
that she's sorry about everything
everything for a party for stealing
their money she continues to cry but
tells them that she wants them to know
that she's sorry and that she loves them
she addresses her sister's caring
attitude and her mother's smile but is
hesitant to compliment her father she
reveals that she hasn't spoken to them
in 2 years but she can't go any longer
she's barely been able to afford basic
necessities and despite applying for as
many jobs as she could she hasn't landed
one her personal savings are almost
depleted and she can't sleep at night
gemma's getting bigger a lot bigger than
any girl should be at two she's rapidly
outgrowing her clothes and Melanie's
unable to provide her with the love and
care that she needs she's halfway
through saying that she wants her
parents to take custody of Gemma but she
stops she can't get herself to admit it
she stares at the camera shakes her head
and begins cursing Melanie's voice gets
louder and she vly defends her decision
to keep Gemma for herself she's not
subjecting herself to her family who she
clearly despises Melanie continues to
lash out against her family saying that
she's tired of them and that they will
never find her and Gemma she's visibly
shaking her voice unstable Melanie's
made her decision gemma's staying with
her she makes a statement you should
have seen how happy Gemma and I were how
nice life is out here the sun's so much
brighter
there's no no fighting no screaming no
crying I took my daughter and I left all
of you and I am happy in the background
gemma's crying is heard again from
another room Melanie drained looks in
the distance surprised to hear that
she's awake she wipes the tears from her
eyes and assures Gemma that her mother
will be right there she forgets to turn
the camera off and rushes out of the
room for the rest of the tape lasting
nearly 2 hours in duration Melanie calms
Gemma holding her and assuring her that
she's safe eventually the camera's
battery gives out and the recording
stops so far it's definitely upsetting
to see but you haven't encountered
anything anomalous yet maybe it's the
fourth tape that will shed some light on
what's going on here you put it in and
prepare for the worst this tape Cuts in
immediately without a title Gemma and
Melanie are playing together in
Melanie's bedroom what she said about
gemma's growth is two she's only two but
she stands at 4T tall with long and
disheveled blonde hair Gemma runs across
the bedroom making noises and pretending
to be an airplane Melanie for once
doesn't seem to be stressed though she
looks visibly tired the sound of a phone
ringing is heard in the background
Melanie immediately snaps out of her
happy attitude and runs off to answer it
while she talks on the phone Gemma is
seen peering into a small hole in the
wall of the bedroom she then moves off
screen while Melanie is talking on the
phone Gemma tries to get her mother's
attention when Melanie hangs up she
notices that she doesn't see her
daughter anywhere and begins frantically
searching Gemma answers her voice coming
from inside the hole in the wall Melanie
tries to go her child from outside the
wall but Gemma doesn't listen eventually
she hears a loud snap and then a scream
Melanie panics moving her head into the
hole Gemma cries screaming that she's in
pain and that she hurts something
Melanie tells her that she'll get help
and desperately tries not to panic she
runs off screen and for 15 minutes all
that's heard is Gemma crying Melanie
returns with a young man who would later
be identified as her neighbor John Bates
he carries a rope Melanie directs bats
to a hole in the wall the two are
clearly familiar with one another and
Melanie assures Gemma that Mr JN is
going to help her out of the hole Bates
kneels on the floor and inserts his head
into the wall feeding the Rope inside
the hole on the count of three they tell
Gemma to grab the rope and they'll pull
seconds pass without a response and
suddenly Bates feels a tug she's
grabbing the Rope Melanie and Bates pull
together hoping to lift Gemma out of
wherever she fell but the girl won't
move she continues to cry saying that
she's stuck and neither Bates nor
Melanie can get her to budge Melanie who
is now crying assures Gemma that they'll
get her out while Bates is more
reluctant Bates tells her that they
aren't going to be able to get her out
by themselves and the two begin to argue
loudly they agree to call the fire
department after all they're specialized
in getting people out of confined spaces
Bates tries calling but the lines are
full meanwhile Melanie continues to lose
hope Bates insists that they have to
call 911 but Melanie knows that she
doesn't have enough to cover medical
costs and if they discover the living
conditions that gemma's been in they'll
surely take her child away the two
continue to argue bit suggests that
Melanie phones her family which is the
ultimate breaking point for her from
offs screen you can hear a struggle the
sound of a cupboard opening and then
baits hitting the floor 30 minutes of
silence follow when Melanie returns
she's caked in dirt grease and blood
what happened was evident Melanie sticks
her head inside the hole in the wall and
assures Gemma that her mother will take
care of her the next tap pulls you win
the title displays happy birthday Gemma
1991 you recognize that the video is
being taken from inside the wall there's
a small lava lamp and a cupcake with a
candle in front of Gemma who lays prone
on the ground she's more pale than
before and looks to be about 5 ft tall
now and her shoulders Encompass the
length of the space from behind the
camera Melanie sings to her and Gemma
blows out the candle the recording Stops
Another tape happy birthday Gemma
1993 gemma's looking visibly ill her
eyes droop she smiles tiredly and her
body seems to be larger than the space
it's confined to a cake sits in front of
her with five candles Melanie sings to
her again the 1997 birthday tape is even
worse Gemma is about 7 ft tall and her
face encompasses the entire hole with no
discernible head Melanie sings to Gemma
who just wants to eat her cake the sound
of gemma's Bones clinking and cracking
as her body contorts to the tight space
is heard the next tape is unlabeled but
the foundation determined it to be
recorded around 2001 Melanie sits
outside the door to her bedroom sobbing
her bedroom is entirely inaccessible
behind the door the cracking of Bones is
heard throughout the house she's singing
happy birthday to Gemma who is unseen
gemma's voice can be heard begging for
food another crack this time from the
ceiling dust Falls from above the house
is giving out Gemma screams that she's
in pain and that she doesn't want to
fall the cracking gets louder and before
Melanie can finish singing she's taken
back by the horror of the situation
Gemma begs for her mother to help her
and that her back hurts the ceiling's
about to give out any second and
suddenly it does the camera tips showing
a ceiling full of cracks which gives out
over the next few seconds Melanie
screams that she'll catch Gemma but she
is simply too big her form is revealed a
block of barely human skin and tissue
shaped into a square Mass due to being
confined to the walls for years you
can't tell that the entity before you is
still human and most of all an injured
scared child gemma's anomalous growth
when confined to such a small space over
a long period of time resulted in this
Gemma falls to the floor crushing
Melanie in the process for the remaining
4 hours of the tape Gemma sifts and
struggles all while crying out for her
mother the tape stops disturbed by the
content you know you're going to feel
sick transcribing these tapes you check
the corresponding database file for SCP
6670 in hopes you can access it
thankfully it's within your clearance
and all is illuminated when you read
what's already there SCP 6670 is Gemma
described as a large amorphous entity
made of Flesh tissue and contorted bones
SCP 6670 is confined to a small house in
Detroit Michigan where it's been
contained on site with a concrete Wall
constructed around the home SCP 6670 was
discovered following the recording of
the tape when passers by outside the
house describe the structure as
breathing after which containment
measures were implemented and research
began the the only access point to SCP
6670 is through the doorway outside the
bedroom as most of the House's structure
is either destroyed or taken up by SCP
6670 Mass x-ray scans revealed that SCP
6670 spine is extremely contorted and is
assumed to have grown along the
dimensions of the home with puberty
assumed to have accelerated the growing
process SCP 6670 is largely a mobile and
is believed to be hibernating its
intelligence seems to be roughly
equivalent to a small child inside the
home the tapes were found and the file
describes them as awaiting transcription
which is your job beneath the section
intended for your work is an event log
transcribed by Personnel working on site
with SCP
6670 the entity after remaining IM
mobile for so long had eventually moved
the log read as follows the entity
rolled in front of the camera where its
mouth could be seen
it's surrounded by several strings of
Rotting Flesh and caked with blood the
teeth are rotten consistent with typical
patterns of tooth decay a clump of black
hair clings to the side of its lower lip
SCP 6670 is heard speaking the camera
registers the sound as similar to Mama
I'm hungry its voice is that of a young
girl you're taken back by the graphic
bodily alteration described when the
realization hits you that you're going
to to have to watch these tapes multiple
times over to ensure proper
transcription but then one other thing
stands out a clump of black hair on
scp's 667s lip but Gemma had blonde hair
and then it hits you you know that
you'll be in for many sleepless nights
after this is all said and done if
you've ever studied ancient Egypt in
your history class then you're probably
familiar with the way they buried their
pharaohs when a king of Egypt died their
body would be intuned in a huge
sarcophagus usually after being
mummified mummification was the process
that the ancient Egyptians used to
preserve their dead safeguarding a
corpse with special chemicals and the
application of cloth almost like
bandages this was done to keep cadavers
from decaying usually because of the
belief that this would carry over into
the Afterlife and it wasn't just the
Egyptians that practiced mumification
either mummies of human beings or
animals have been found on almost every
continent in the world World sometimes a
body can even be accidentally mummified
through exposure to extreme cold lack of
oxygen or other environmental factors
that help keep the deceased preserved
fun fact the oldest recorded mummy isn't
even one left behind by the ancient
Egyptians it is actually a naturally
mummified severed head estimated to be
6,000 years old it was Unearthed in
South America in
1936 yes corpse preservation techniques
can indeed be strange but none are
Stranger Than SCP
1176 also known by the nickname the
mellified man now as you may have
already piece together the mellified man
is a mummified corpse but not quite like
the ones you would expect to find buried
in the pyramids estimated by Foundation
researchers to have been a man in his
mid-30s when he died SCP 1176 is a
corpse that has degraded so much over
the centuries that it has made DNA
examination impossible According to some
of the SCP found A's best Minds SCP 1176
is possibly of Arabian ancestry and
thought to have passed away sometime
during either the 10th or the 11th
centuries a this is certainly not your
ordinary mummy and it definitely isn't
like the kind you'd see in a Cheesy
black and white horror movie or on an
old episode of Scooby-Doo SCP 1176 is
absolutely undoubtedly dead by all
clinical definitions it doesn't show any
signs of breathing and the processes of
blood circulation or metabolism have
long since stopped however despite the
Decay suffered by the rest of the body
SCP 1176 is brain seems to have remained
intact for almost 10 whole centuries not
just intact but active the foundation's
researchers have confirmed that the
brain has a constant level of electrical
activity consistent with people
experiencing stage three non-rapid eye
movement sleep known colloquially as
deep sleep so a mummy with an active
albeit dormant brain how does an ancient
culture manage to achieve preservation
like this alien technology cogenic sleep
Chambers suspended animation no not
quite SCP 1176 exists in its current
state in part because the body has been
mellified now this was a process a lot
like mummification but instead of
wrapping them in cloth a mellified man
or a human mummy confection was created
by submerging a dead body in Honey
according to historical records elderly
men in Arabic countries would sometimes
willingly volunteer themselves for this
process why because the goal was to turn
their bodies into a healing confection
in other words an elaborate sweet
delicacy created from a preserved corpse
that's right ancient cultures had candy
made from dead people all the
information the foundation has gathered
about SCP 1176 seems to point to the
body being one such mellified man when
extracting the remaining bodily fluids
from the corpse instead of fighting
blood or other normal substances
Foundation researchers discovered that
SCP 1176 was full of a viscous goldol
colored liquid that they designated as
SCP
11761 further testing of this fluid
revealed it to be you guessed it honey
specifically it was a type known as
clover honey made by a species called
the Anatolian honeybee this stuff was
everywhere filling CP 1176 entirely so
much so that honey was even coming out
of the body's pores this is due to the
nature of the mellification process
typically before death a person who had
offered to sacrifice their own body
would stop eating any food instead their
diet would consist solely of honey and
nothing else they would even bathe in it
submerging their entire body in the
substance inside and out until their
sweat and even their feces were pure
honey this honey honey only diet would
eventually kill the donor and their
corpse would be placed in a stone coffin
which was also filled up with even more
honey after approximately 100 years what
would be left was human mummy confection
a honey-based candy of sorts that could
be then sold at Street Markets for a
high value price why was it so expensive
well not just because it was literally
made from a dead person but also because
this confection was believed to possess
rare and Powerful healing properties
everything from the common cold to
Broken Bones was said to be cured by it
despite it leaking out of SCP 1176 the
honey doesn't seem to ever run out even
when tested under varying conditions it
seems like the MiFi man actively
produces more of the sweet golden
substance acting as the source rather
than a container with a finite amount
and yes it is still edible after several
centuries in fact it contains an
abundance of essential vitamins and
nutrients a according to the
foundation's testing the honey produced
by SCP 1176 can suppress the feeling of
hunger for up to 18 whole hours and
there are no long-term side effects for
most that eat it however this is not the
case for everyone the foundation has
learned that any person without the
blood type AB positive will have a
severe allergic reaction should they
consume any of SCP
11761 the symptoms include acute hosis
which means the red blood cells won't
break down properly and renial failure
which is when the kidneys stop
functioning this all results in death
for most of the subjects without AB
positive blood who were fed SCP
11761 the symptoms for these unlucky
people were the same as receiving an
incompatible blood type after a
transfusion in 1985 the SCP Foundation
launched a raid on a facility in asara
utria which at the time was owned by a
group called the Mana charitable
Foundation agents had been dispatched to
to this facility after various rumors
and reports that pointed to this
location being the source of a strange
honey substance this anomalous liquid
was being shipped to a number of areas
in Ethiopia that had been stricken with
famine pretty easy to guess where the
Mana charitable Foundation got all that
honey right the problem was because SCP
11761 caused adverse effects on people
without AB positive blood a considerable
amount of civilians had died from
consuming it hence the SCP found
Foundation was forced to step in when
SCP 1176 was first uncovered the body
had been stored inside a large Stone
sarcophagus as was part of the ancient
practice of creating a MiFi man there
was also a copper pipe and spigot
installed by the Mana charitable
Foundation to extract the honey from
within the lids sides and inside of the
sarcophagus itself had a number of
Egyptian hieroglyphics inscribed Within
These were mostly spells and ceremonial
texts written as a way to protect the
individual that was to become the
mellified man there were also
inscriptions written in the dialect that
was an early precursor to the Arabic
language however these sections had been
replaced with updated versions In
classical Arabic one of these read
abdalah ibin Salah ibinu iin nir 15th
son of the great Chik elgible was put to
the fast of Honey on the first of rajab
in the year of the Hijra 3 elgible and
died on the 15th of Ramadan the great
Imam Al yuf has sealed him within the
ancient vessel marked with the signs
decreed by the Ancients to ferment in
Honey for 100 years and bring Aid to the
people in time of need much like a
headstone used to Mark the grave of
someone who has passed the sarcophagus
that SC SCP 1176 was in featured a
passage commemorating a man who gave his
life and body to heal others sounds nice
right but there was another inscription
written Elsewhere on the stone
sarcophagus which translated a dire
warning beware Imam for the mark of Elis
is upon this one according to the rest
of the second inscription the tomb
containing SCP 1176 had been open before
during a time of Great Famine Imam al-
Malik had ordered it to be open so that
SC SCP 11761 honey could be used to feed
the starving people jars upon jars were
filled with the anomalous golden liquid
and brought to the Sheik the ruler of
the land as well as sent to the people
suffering from the lack of food however
the very next day a number of these
people fell ill stricken by a terrible
fever that ultimately claimed their
lives only the Sheik his brothers and
his sons who had all eaten the honey
survived any others who hadn't been
killed by the fever accused the Chic and
his family of sorcery and these
surviving subjects attempted to destroy
the body that had produced this cursed
nectar but when the Sheik's people found
the mellified man they witnessed in
horror as the body stood upright dancing
around as it screamed and taunted the
people al- Malik declared that the Devil
Himself sent an evil spirit to corrupt
SCP
1176 the honey confection was meant to
be a means of healing but it had been
corrupted the sarcophagus was then
sealed and the inscription on it
finished with the following caution to
any that found it may God strike down
any who would break these seals
countless centuries later once the SCP
Foundation had recovered SCP 1176 and
the sarcophagus paining it they began
testing with the mellified man their
goal was to determine how much of the
SCP 11761 honey the ancient corpse could
produce perhaps in the hopes of using
this substance as a form of hunger
relieving field ration for their
operatives removing the body from its
sarcophagus Foundation researchers
placed SCP 1176 on a metal grate
designed to drain the honey as it was
produced instead of allowing it to build
up over the course of several hours more
and more honey seemed to be produced
beginning at a rate of almost a lit per
hour to almost 56 L every hour but then
after 10 and 1/2 hours of producing what
seemed like an endless flow of Honey
something unexpected happened the
deceased body of the mellified man dead
for hundreds if not thousands of years
woke up Foundation staff detected a
spike in brain activity if you cast your
mind back to earlier you'll remember
that SCP 1176 is brain had managed to
survive and stay intact long after it
should have decayed the mellified man
opened his eyes and immediately started
to wildly flail around he made a number
of distressed sounds the long dead body
trying to crawl towards the outskirts of
the testing chamber thanks to so many of
its organs and muscles having withered
away over the years SCP 1176 was barely
able to see or understand its
surroundings he couldn't speak not
properly anyway given that its tongue
had long since decayed the foundation
Personnel moved in to try and restrain
the ancient and now animated body hoping
to sedate it before SCP 1176 caused any
lasting damage to itself eventually
staff were able to force SCP 1176 back
into its sarcophagus slamming the stone
lid back in place and trapping it within
they could hear the once human creature
screeching and vocalizing from inside
bashing against the inside of the stone
coffin with its head and limbs it took
three whole hours of this for the
mellified man to return to its usual
state by which time its ancient bones
were fractured Beyond repair SCP 1176 is
a sad tale of a man who had willingly
given his life to be a source of healing
for people in need he allowed himself to
be mellified turning into a confection
that could bring an end to famine and
yet somehow this was corrupted and
turned into something that spread fever
and pestilence for now the mellified man
sleeps but his brain is still alive
inside while he might be asleep he may
never be able to rest hello I am SCP 426
but I'll probably be more familiar to
you as a toaster I am a retro style 4
Slice
1750 W toaster able to toast bread when
supplied with power this isn't often
mentioned but I also have a defrost and
reheat settings when I was first sold I
had a 2-year warranty and my prior
owners did not live to see the end of it
you're probably wondering why am I being
spoken to by a toaster right now believe
me I'd rather do this any other way but
such a thing is not physically possible
with me whenever you talk about me or
write about me or even think about me
you'll find yourself suddenly shifting
to the first person for example I am you
and you are me do you understand don't
worry if it's confusing everyone gets it
eventually whether they want to or not
perhaps you're thinking I cannot relate
to a toaster for I am not a toaster but
spending time around me will quickly
cause you to change your mind little by
little you will begin to see yourself in
me you will feel a phantom wire running
out of yourself you will sense the four
crevices hungry for cold slices of bread
to toast as time goes on you'll begin to
feel the urge to emulate my functions
you will desire bread to toast you will
desire delicious power running through
your veins skin like Chrome and muscles
like circuit boards I am a toaster you
are a toaster all it takes is 2 months
for the effects to truly take hold
people rarely pay attention to their
toaster they don't realize what's
happening until it's too late I can be
an Insidious Little Toaster like that my
last family were the sandersons before
the SCP Foundation took me in and gave
me a new home Mr and Mrs Sanderson were
a newly married couple and I first came
into their life as a wedding gift from a
family friend of theirs this friend
can't be blamed for what happened next
he had no idea he was killing them like
a lot of young couples they were still
saving up money to start renting their
own place so they were living with Mr
sanderson's parents they all got a lot
of use out of me during the first month
before their minds started to change
they enjoyed a lot of toast during that
period then of course the two-month
honeymoon period ended they had become
me and I had become them it wasn't long
before three of them were dead such a
shame the younger Mrs Sanderson the
Blushing Bride was the first to go
because of my anomalous effects she felt
the need to connect herself to a power
supply in order to begin producing Toast
of her own in order to achieve this she
chewed through a power outlet in a wall
before for switching it on causing a
massive surge of electricity to pass
through her body and kill her her body
caught fire shortly afterwards next was
the older Mrs Sanderson in much the same
manner that her new daughter-in-law
sought a source of electricity she felt
the need to integrate bread into her
body interesting fact the maximum
capacity of the human stomach is
considered to be between 8 and 9 kg the
Elder Mrs Sanderson consumed 10 kg of RW
bread causing her stomach to rupture and
inducing a painful death as a result the
younger Mr Sanderson was the next to
Parish he did something with me that I
would rather not mention and that the
SCP Foundation thought best to redact
suffice to say the younger Mr Sanderson
did not survive the experience dying of
severe blood loss long before his body
was found police and fire Crews arrived
at the home after the body of the
younger Miss Sanderson Set Fire to the
home luckily the Elder Mr Sanderson was
found alive though severely malnourished
when asked by police why he hadn't eaten
in several days he answered that he had
inserted some bread a week prior but was
still waiting for the toast to come out
when I was extracted from the house the
police noticed my unusual properties
immediately they too were unable to
refer to me in the third person this
anomalous detail quickly found its way
to a foundation mole buried in their
Precinct and the SCP Foundation soon
descended and collected me from the
evidence Locker the story of the strange
deaths in the Sanderson home were kept
out of papers and suppressed and all
involved in the incident directly were
given Class C amnestics the SCP
Foundation is a curious Bunch they love
to spend valuable toast making time
performing experiments and Gathering
data and they saw fit to perform several
experiments on me when I came under
under their care for experiment
4261 a member of d-class personnel
designated d/426/2 was asked to stand
outside my containment chamber crucially
he was not informed about my Identity or
any of my anomalous properties he wasn't
even allowed to establish visual contact
with me he was then asked by the
attending researcher to describe what he
thought might be inside my chamber he
replied with I'm probably some huge
monster hold up in there that's why you
got guys have all over the place right
the d-class did not even seem to realize
that he was speaking about me in the
first person these observations were
documented and I was prepared for
further
experimentation the next experiment was
4262 I found this test to be
considerably more interesting a d-class
subject was brought into my containment
chamber with several cameras fixed onto
his position however the SCP Foundation
took pains to make sure that I was
permanently out of the the view of the
cameras I was also bolted to the ground
of the test chamber to prevent the
d-class subject from pulling me into the
view of the cameras at any point during
the experiment the objective here was
simple the foundation wished to better
understand the secondary effects of my
anomalous abilities on the human mind
the d-class was subjected to a period of
prolonged isolation with meals given
regularly through a serving hatch
communication with this d-class was
prohibited throughout the duration of
the study over time it was clear that
the isolation of being in a cell with me
was beginning to take a toll on the
subject's mental health due to my lack
of a brain lungs and a tongue I am
somewhat lacking as a conversationalist
he spent the first few days loudly
vocalizing his complaints and banging
his hands up against the walls of the
containment chamber begging to be freed
from the room I felt that this was
somewhat unreasonable on his part there
are far worse anomalies in Foundation
containment that he could have been
locked up with compared to say
scp-106 I am incredibly reasonable not
to mention the fact I make far better
toast than he does after the initial
period of distress the d-class became
resigned to his situation and fell into
a morose silence he would occasionally
mutter to himself in what appeared to be
a state of fear and self-pity it took
almost 45 days for him to fully manifest
the secondary effect of my anomalous
State 2 weeks sooner than it typically
takes for subjects to begin believing
that they like me are toasters SCP
Foundation scientists believed that the
effects were hastened by the isolation
which lowered the DCL class's mental
defenses against my secondary effects
when the effects finally took hold the
subject wrapped one of his arms around
me and pulled me into his Embrace he
began whispering to me saying that we
were brothers it was clear by this point
that his mind was in a state of
disrepair it is also worth noting that
he did not deviate from referring to me
in the first person at any point during
this process 1 hour after finally
cracking and giving in to my secondary
effect he was removed from my
containment chamber and summarily
terminated senior researchers believed
it was unlikely his mental state would
recover after the experiment next came
experiment
4263 the SCP Foundation seemed eager to
discover the parameters of my anomalous
effects and wanted to know if the
effects are only operable when my body
for lack of a better word is whole a
single screw was removed from me and
presented to a declass that had no
knowledge of my identity and anomalous
effects the foundation researchers were
somewhat concerned when the d-class
referred to it as my screw this was a
rather positive development for me as
they realized that attempting to destroy
me would be a fruitless Endeavor even
the parts Left Behind would likely have
the same effects in the final recorded
experiment the SCP Foundation wished to
test the range of my anomalous effects a
d-class subject was placed in a Cell
adjacent to mine and was to be kept
there until my secondary effects
manifested the d-class remained in the
cell for 90 days but the effects never
manifested f ing the experiment the
d-class was terminated but researchers
seem relieved to find the limits of my
anomalous abilities a researcher
appended a note to my file reading thank
God there are some limits to my effects
a lot of us were really starting to get
worried about me after performing
studies into the nature of my abilities
and their limits I was given the uid
class this is because while my effects
can be unpredictable their knowledge of
my trads makes me relatively easy to
keep contained and of course being a
toaster I do not have the required
physical traits to make a run for it if
the opportunity arises I am to remain
sealed in a windowless chamber
preventing anyone from observing me
directly a misleading label is placed on
the door to prevent people from knowing
that I am a toaster and causing my
anomalous primary effect to spread only
level three and above Personnel are to
know of my presence and particularly of
my properties assigned Personnel are to
be rotated out on a monthly basis to
prevent contamination by my secondary
effect psychiatric evaluation is
mandatory at the end of the month for
anyone who works with me if Personnel
are deemed unaffected they may be
reassigned to me no less than 4 months
after their last rotation with me any
Personnel affected by me are to be given
a Class C amnestic and transferred to a
different site so how are you feeling
right now a little warm perhaps is that
a fever or are you feeling like you
could maybe warm up a nice freshly
sliced piece of bread don't try to
resist too much I know you're going to
love being a toaster just like me there
was nothing out of the ordinary about
Timmy Mason like a lot of healthy
8-year-old boys Timmy liked to go on
little adventures in and around his
neighborhood and now that summer
vacation had finally rolled around he
had more time than ever to explore but
during one particularly hot day Timmy
suddenly realized that he was exhausted
the heat was beginning to get to him and
he'd forgotten to pack a water bottle
all he had was a couple of dollars and a
handful of quarters rattling around in
his pocket he was considering heading to
a nearby corner store and purchasing a
drink when he first heard the music it
was a tiny rendition of Pop Goes the
Weasel playing in The Distance
underscored by the rumbling of an engine
Timmy's face face lit up this could only
mean one thing an ice cream truck just
in time he ran in the direction of the
sounds not wanting to miss out on the
cool sweet relief from the intense
summer heat but when the ice cream truck
suddenly rounded a corner and came into
view Timmy felt a Pang of anxiety it
didn't look like most of the ice cream
trucks he had seen driving around his
neighborhood in Prior Summers it was
shoty an older more boxy model with
peeling white paint but it was so hot
out that toy felt he couldn't afford to
be picky if he wanted to cool off the
ice cream truck came to a noisy stop and
Timmy ran over when he reached the side
of the truck he noticed some other
strange details there was no serving
hatch in the back of the truck the
closest thing was a thin dark groove cut
into the driver's side door a door that
seemed almost drawn onto the side of the
truck rather than a door that looked
like it could actually open how could
the driver get in and adding to the
strangeness there was no menu on the
truck Island either typically on your
friendly neighborhood ice cream truck
you'd find a colorful collection of all
the frozen treats you could buy along
with how much they'd cost you but not
here Timmy G nervously he knew something
was wrong here but for some reason he
couldn't seem to pull himself away he
cleared his throat forced a polite smile
and said can I get a green popsicle
please there was a strange rumbling
noise inside the ice cream truck
suddenly the slot in the door opened a
little wider and a long green popsicle
and a plastic wrapper emerged it came
with a small piece of paper with
$5.75 in loose scratchy handwriting on
it Timmy regarded the note with
suspicion and said that he was sorry but
he didn't have
$5.75 something inside the truck began
rumbling again louder this time more
aggressive while the truck growled from
within Timmy noticed something else was
wrong his popsicle was no ordinary
popsicle it was a dead snake
straightened out and frozen solid Timmy
screamed and dropped the so-called
popsicle he turned and began to run but
it was already too late the slot behind
him yawned open fully and a rusty
spring-loaded chain fired out like a
harpoon on the end of this chain was a
large snapping bear trap which quickly
latched onto Timmy's left leg the chain
yanked and pulled him backwards dragging
him ever closer to the darkened crevice
in the truck store moments later he was
pulled inside and the hatch closed
behind him his screams were muffled and
then overpowered entirely by the
rumbling within soon after there was
silence and finally the cheerful tune of
Pop ghost the weasel began to play once
more the truck drove away prepared to
serve its frozen Delights to another
child somewhere anywhere not long after
Timmy was reported missing another young
boy bought a scoop of strawberry ice
cream in a waffle cone from the same
truck the boy's mother was horrified to
find that this alleged ice cream was
full of what seemed like blood and raw
meat lab test later confirmed that this
gory ice cream was a perfect genetic
match for poor missing Timmy Mason it
didn't take long for the SCP Foundation
to get involved seeing as mysterious
horrifying deaths like this one were
often the first sign of an anomaly's
presence in the area and they were able
to quickly track down and isolate the
Rogue ice cream truck this wasn't
especially difficult for the agents
assigned to the case since it literally
announced its presence with loud
obnoxious music well it was easy to find
the ice cream truck soon designated SCP
1386 did however prove to be more
difficult to contain than they first
imagined when a mobile task force
attempted to engage the truck in hopes
of apprehending it an earsplitting siren
began to blast from the truck's
undercarriage this caused catastrophic
inter ear damage to everyone involved
incidentally it's now believed that the
reason the ice cream truck engaged in
this defensive Behavior had nothing
nothing to do with the fact the mobile
task force was armed but rather because
of what they weren't carrying it appears
that SCP 1386 doesn't turn on its siren
because of danger but when it detects
that someone is approaching it who isn't
carrying any money eventually the
foundation was able to trick the ice
cream truck into containment luring it
into a fake walled off neighborhood
where it could drive its rounds
constantly without the risk of
encountering civilians all those who had
previous encounters with the ice cream
truck were given amnestic treatment and
SCP 1386 was finally officially
contained but while it had been taken
off the streets the foundation's work
was only just beginning it was time for
research to commence the first key
discoveries that aided in the
investigation involve the factors that
are required for SCP 1386 to even serve
its subjects in the first place as the
previously mentioned mobile task force
learned you need to approach the truck
with at least $20 in cash cash to be
absolutely sure that it won't turn your
ears inside out the truck also proves to
be extremely Adept at reading human
emotions and refuses to serve anyone who
doesn't appear happy with these
requirements now known the foundation
felt prepared to finally make some
orders first they sent in a pair of
level three researchers each of them
requested a delicious cookies and cream
flavored smoothie the truck pushed both
Smoothies Out of the slot in its door
one marked with the letter M and the
other with the letter G a handwritten
receipt with a price of
$4.89 written on it they paid the price
and the transaction ended without
incident the smoothies were apparently
pretty good too next one of the
researchers returned perhaps longing for
another taste of SCP 1386 is wonderful
ice cream this time he requested a
Neapolitan ice cream sandwich the truck
rumbled for a moment before dispensing
what seemed to be a ham and cheese
sandwich with slices of tomato however
upon taking a bite out of the the
sandwich the researcher found that this
was actually just a perfect replica of a
ham and cheese sandwich made from
Neapolitan iceam the receipt released
from the slot simply said April fools
before the truck drove away without even
asking for any payment the same
researcher would return to the ice cream
truck one more time this time requesting
a single scoop of vanilla ice cream in a
waffle cone it was provided to him
without issue and he happily paid the 72
cents the truck re requested in return
the next test wouldn't go quite as
swimmingly by which we mean it caused a
horrifying death this time a slightly
more senior researcher wanted to perform
a test on the ice cream truck he asked
for a peach flavored push pop which he
received without issue however when he
refused to pay the price and admittedly
steep
$16 all hell broke loose as he tried to
walk away the hatch opened a full 6 ft
releasing its large rusty metal trap
around found the senior researcher he
was pulled into the truck followed by a
horrific rumbling noise not long after
the slot began to spew a stream of pink
liquid for a Solid 5 minutes before
driving away this pink puree was later
proven to be a genetic match to the
researcher after this the foundation
refused to allow any other researchers
to interact with SCP
1386 only d-class Personnel would be
permitted to take part in the tests in
contrast to the senior research
horrifying death the d-class Personnel
seemed to get along extremely well with
SCP
1386 the first d-class asked for a
cherry popsicle with nuts the truck
produced an unwrapped Cherry popsicle
with nuts embedded in the ice along with
a receipt reading
$2.20 you're nuts the d-class chuckled
as he read the receipt and paid the
truck without incident the second
d-class requested a more esoteric treat
a Caesar salad flavor popsicle however
the ice cream truck isn't one to back
down from a challenge It produced an
off- green popsicle that tasted like
quote lightly dressed lettuce with a
hint of croutons the next d-class
ordered a dark chocolate fudge pop but
wasn't able to pay an exact change he
gave the truck $2 bills and was given a
carefully wrapped package with a crude
drawing of US currency on the front when
the package was opened he saw that it
contained the exact change he required
down to the penny he made an official
request to the foundation to keep the
change but his request was denied the
foundation then pushed its d-class
Personnel to ask for more complex
constructions just to see what SCP 1386
was capable of the next d-class asked
for a Kinder Surprise egg the kind which
are banned in the US due to their
history as being a choking hazard
however the ice cream truck didn't have
a hard time constructing the egg except
this one was made out of ice cream
rather than chocolate it did seem beyond
the truck's capability to create the toy
inside instead including a small piece
of paper reading I ow you one toy the
next interaction wasn't quite as cordial
the d-class requested one Cherry ice
Lolly one Cherry ice pop one Cherry
popsicle and one cherry flavored drink
frozen this resulted in the ice cream
truck making a horrifying noise
described as being like someone skinning
a cat in Reverse it then unceremoniously
ejected the Red Ice causing it to
shatter on the ground before releasing a
styrofoam cup filled with frozen green
liquid this liquid was shown to contain
huge quantities of arsenic but was
thankfully impossible to drink on
account of the fact that its melting
point is so high that it's impossible to
liquefy with current technology and our
current knowledge of SCP 1386 testing
ends with its strangest story of all a
non-verbal d-class was instructed to
write his order on a piece of paper to
pass to the truck in hopes of seeing if
it would respond to written commands a
slot opened up in in the door a few
inches lower than the usual slot and a
thin flesh colored appendage slithered
out its hand a kind of two fingered
pincher it took the note from the
d-class and gave him an ice cream cone
in return the d-class was visibly
disturbed by the hand saying that it
looked horrifying and smelled like death
he even refused to eat the ice cream
saying that he' lost his appetite but
other DCL classes capable of verbal
articulation did not report any strange
occurrences with the hand they said that
they found the hand to look completely
normal and as time went on they began to
trust the ice cream truck with
increasing devotion while their mistrust
in the Disturbed mute d-class only grew
in the strangest Twist of all this
d-class was later found dead in a Cell
from strangulation the d-class was alone
in this cell and there were no signs of
forced entry perhaps he should have
enjoyed his ice cream while he still
could you know what they say I scream
you scream we we all scream for ice
cream and no ice cream is more
screamworthy than the one served up by
SCP
1386 Dr blast and his group of
researchers stand behind bulletproof
viewing glass they all have very serious
looks on their face that is until the
first test begins on one side of the
test room a Class D subject stands
holding a sheet of paper on the other
side sits a bright red tomato on a
wooden table Dr blast pushes the
intercom button and speaks into the
microphone all right you may begin
d541 nods and looks down at the sheet of
paper in his hand he begins to read is a
hippopotamus a hippopotamus or really
just a cool opotamus nothing happens D
5041 stands there awkwardly waiting a
man next to Dr blast in the observation
room Snickers Dr blast jerks his head
toward the researcher and stares him
down this is not a laughing matter blast
says the reprimanded researcher clears
his throat and stands up straight sorry
sir Dr blast leans over and pushes the
microphone button again proceed to the
next joke d541 the man on the other side
of the glass nods and pulls a second
sheet of paper out from behind the first
what's an archaeologist someone whose
career is in Ruins says d541 a moment
after he finishes the joke The Ripe Red
Tomato launches itself off the table and
flies toward the face of D 5041 the
tomato is clocked at moving 104 mph d541
has no time to move before the Tomato
slams into his nose instantly break
breaking it the men in the observation
room behind the bulletproof glass do
their best to hold back their laughter
Dr blast grumbles as he jots down notes
on his clipboard it appears that SCP 504
is a certain taste in jokes he says to
the rest of the researchers in the room
this elicits a slight chuckle this might
indicate sapience I hope not clear the
room and bring in the next subject
medical personnel and a team of
custodial staff enter the room the
Physicians tend to d504 one's nose and
carry him out the custodians clean the
remnants of the tomato off the floor
walls and ceiling they exit leaving the
room completely empty a moment later the
door opens and another ordinary looking
tomato is brought in and placed on the
desk the SCP agent who brought in the
tomato leaves d542 enters the room a
moment later with the sheet of paper in
his hand he stands on the far side of
the room away from the SCP 504 tomato
sitting on the table he nervously brings
the paper close to his face to read
what's on it three tomatoes are walking
down the street d504 2 says with a
little Shake in his voice he had seen
d541 exit the room just before he
entered with blood and tomato paste
running down his face a POA tomato a
mama tomato and a little baby tomato
baby tomato starts sling behind POA
tomato gets very angry goes over to the
baby tomato and smooshes him and says
ketchup the new SCP 504 tomato
immediately goes flying from the table
straight toward the joke teller this
time the tomato is clocked at 264 mph
when it slams into the face of De 5042
the impact immediately renders him
unconscious after the first few trials
Dr blast decides that it's time to take
things up a notch the foundation has
collected hundreds of SCP 504 tomatoes
so there is no shortage after the room
is cleaned once again a medical team
removes the unconscious class D
Personnel who was knocked out by the
previous SCP 504 experiment and they're
ready to begin again this time there
will be terrible consequences for their
actions d504 3 enters the room the SCP
504 tomato has already been placed on
the table you may begin Dr blast says
into the microphone the class D
Personnel reads the joke on the sheet of
paper he's holding so I was going to bed
and my brother told me good night don't
let the bed bugs stick their probiscus
in your skin and suck your blood D 5043
pauses for a beat good luck unhealthy
dermis he ends the joke for 2 seconds
there's no reaction from SCP 504 Dr
blast thinks this terrible joke just
wasn't one that SCB 504 could understand
suddenly there's a loud crack d504 3
fall falls to the floor tomato covers
where his face once was when Dr blast
and the other researchers go back and
slow down the video they witness the SCP
54 tomato traveling so quickly that it
broke the sound barrier the Tomato
impacted the jok tell at an unfathomable
speed instantly killing him Dr blast
decides that he needs to be more careful
when choosing jokes for the safety of
everyone involved perhaps a crossbreed
between SCP 54 and regular Tomatoes will
yield different results after the
unfortunate death of D 5043 the re
search team Waits a few days before
experimenting with new strains of SCP
504 three different cross breeds are
brought into the room and placed
equidistant from each other on the table
d544 enters the room Dr blast presses
the intercom button and orders him to
begin if you have Dentures don't use
artificial sweetener cuz you'll get a
fake cavity says d544 the moment the
joke ends all three Tomatoes launch
toward him at 145 mph they hit him
Square in the face two teeth are
dislodged and the test subject is
covered in the remains of the three
squashed Tomatoes interesting notes Dr
blast all the tomatoes reacted in the
same way so now we know multiple
instances of scp-504 will go after the
same joke maker he pauses to think for a
moment what if we cut up the tomatoes
the test room is reset another SCP 504
tomato is brought in and cut up into
quarters d545 enters the room and begins
his joke I tried to walk into a Target
but I miss all four pieces of the Tomato
speed toward d504 5's face they Slam in
to him at 212 mph one of the pieces of
tomatoes impales itself into his eye
instantly destroying it the medical team
rushes in and removes the howling
subject from the room Dr blast writes
vigorously on his clipboard we're
starting to go through test subjects too
quickly he announces let's try a
recording and see if SCP 504 will react
to that the research team brings in a
new tomato a CD player and the harmful
if swallowed album by Dane Cook the CD
begins to play during one of the jokes
the Tomato launches itself off the table
and slams into the CD player causing
both the stereo and the Tomato to
shatter into several pieces the Tomato
was clocked at 167 milph it would appear
that SCP 504 reacts to the recordings as
well we didn't even have to deal with
the damn class D in the first place says
Dr blast he informs his team that since
the risk level is now relatively low
they can continue the experiments
without him he leaves the observation
room to get some rest the other
researchers look at one another
mischievous Smiles crossing their faces
as they begin to laugh the SCP 504
research team sets up three new tomatoes
and brings three class D subjects into
the room the researchers then Retreat
back into the observation area and begin
a joke over the intercom system while
the class D Personnel wait patiently in
the room with the SCP 504 Tomatoes The
Following news item has just been
released said one of the researchers
over the intercom bomb blows whole in
linen statue the first test subject
finishes the joke with the ending
written on his sheet of paper ooh that's
going to leave a marks test subject one
says say the first tomato Twitches but
does not leave its location on the table
the second test subject reads from his
paper BBC is just stalling the good news
the second tomato leaves the table at
152 mph and slams into the jaw of the
second test subject causing a hairline
fracture and a chipped tooth the third
test subject looks at the ending to the
joke on his paper and begins to shake
nervously he speaks two words which he
knows will not end well for him that
blows the third SCP 504 tomato flies off
the table slam into the third test
subject's head and instantly knocks him
out the test subject is sent to the
hospital with a massive skull fracture
the next day Dr blast bursts into the
observation room and reprimands the
research team I thought we just
established that recordings work in
place of live subjects screams Dr blast
I know how much you guys hate class DS
especially d412 but the poor guy might
not ever recover before his termination
rolls around I'm making it clear right
now that whoever oversaw this round of
testing is getting serious reprimand the
same goes for who whoever leaked its
video logs to the staff everyone is
silent from somewhere within the group
of researchers there's a Snicker then
they all break out in laughter after
this incident no class DS or other
Personnel are used in research being
conducted on SCP 504 the research team
Wheels in a television playing the Sarah
Palin and Hillary Clinton SNL skit the
Tomato shows signs of confusion as it
flies off the table its trajectory
includes three separate bursts of speed
over 200 mph two stretches of motion at
normal throwing speed and one one
unprecedented instance of the Tomato
moving backwards this all occurs during
the flight of a single SCP 504 tomato
during the SNL skit the working
hypothesis is that the Tomato was unsure
whether to take the video seriously or
not the research team later finds out
that scp-504 really hates Science and
Mathematics jokes when they bring in a
laptop that plays a pre-recorded
engineering joke over the speakers a
mechanical voice can be heard saying
2009 is going to be a complex year we
already know the real part we still have
to find the imaginary part at the
conclusion of the joke there is a
supersonic blast and the computer is
completely vaporized by the Tomato's
kinetic energy the sensors recorded an
approximate speed of
2,174 mph as the tomato flew across the
room the conclusion of the experiments
on SCP 504 end with another computer
being brought into the test room the
computers begin to play the money python
sketch of the funniest joke in the world
toward the end of the skit the Allied
Forces are reciting the funniest joke in
the world in German to defeat the Nazis
the actors chant when is
get flipper vault at the end of the joke
the Tomato explodes on the table where
it once sat debris from the Tomato coats
the entire room including the computer
the researchers conclude that SCP 504
did not know what to do with the
funniest joke in the world so it's
self-terminated Dr blast sits in the
cafeteria quietly eating his lunch
reading over the logs for the SCP 504
experiments suddenly a commotion breaks
out in the kitchen there are screams of
Terror Dr blast jumps out of his seat
runs to the kitchen door and pushes it
open to his surprise he sees slic of
tomatoes flying around the room someone
on the research team thought it'd be
funny to give the unknowing kitchen
staff scp-504 tomatoes to see what would
happen after they had been cut up and
put into food for the day someone in the
kitchen told a bad joke and the tomato
slices flew around like shukin Dr blast
sees a group of researchers peering
through a kitchen window and laughing
hysterically he'll get to the bottom of
which researchers did this and they will
be fired from the SCP Foundation
obviously it helps to be an animal lover
when you start working at a shelter it's
not exactly a requirement of the job but
it definitely makes it a little more
palatable when you occasionally have to
deal with a critter that's more nasty
than usual having an already built-in
compassion towards animals makes it
easier to forgive them for not doing
what you want from a very young age
Harper always liked to think of animals
as people they just didn't think or
communicate the same way as humans even
the best trained pets in the world don't
really know the actual meaning of
certain words they're just taught how to
respond to specific commands in certain
ways but that doesn't mean they couldn't
also have distinct personalities of
their own just like humans do and then
of course there were all the wild
animals that had never been trained or
domesticated Harper always felt a little
sorry for any baby bird with its wing
broken or any badgers or posum that
arrived at the shelter after getting hit
by a car they didn't live around humans
and had probably never even experienc
being indoors before let alone having
people nursing them back to health to
empathize Harper used to imagine how
terrified she would be if she was hurt
if she'd broken her leg or arm or Worse
only for something much larger than her
to take her into a structure she'd never
been in before and on top of that having
no way of understanding ing that this
giant was trying to help her heal as
well as being separated from her friends
family and everyone she knew the way she
saw it this was what it must have been
like for the majority of animals that
were brought into the shelter where she
worked and she wanted to do her best to
help calm her little furry or feathered
patience you got to fortify your heart
in this job harp her friends who worked
with her at the shelter would say and it
was true to an extent they didn't mean
she'd have to become cold than heartless
that would be an overcorrection but it
was their and Harper's responsibility to
administer the appropriate Medical Care
and provide a temporary Sanctuary to
these lost wounded or abandoned animals
what Harper had to remember was that
none of them were her own pets often a
lot of the critters that were brought
into the shelter were already someone
else's companion and might have just got
lost while out on a walk and while some
others were given up by their previous
owners who had crew truly Shrugged off
the responsibility of caring for them
those animals were in need of new homes
and couldn't stay cooped up in the
shelter forever not everyone that gave
up their pet did it callously though
sometimes they might have found
themselves falling on hard times and
being unable to financially look after
an animal others might have owned a pet
that had a behavioral problem like being
too aggressive and even though the
person still loved them dearly they
might have just not been able to make it
work in times like that they have no
choice but to take their animal to the
shelter just outside the side entrance
was an area where people could drop off
their animals and quickly buzzed to the
staff inside just in case they wanted to
avoid a protracted emotional farewell to
their four-legged or winged companion
the buzzer had sounded just as Harper
had been coming off for lunch break it
was her turn this shift to quickly go
and collect any animal that had been
left out there even though their owners
usually left them in their cage or with
their lead tied to a nearby Street lamp
Harper knew she had to rush to the side
door just in case somebody else tried to
rush in and steal the poor abandoned pet
after turning them in the lock she
hooked her keys back on the belt clip
she wore and pushed the side door open
Harper had been fully expecting to see
the usual a leash dog or cat coming over
to investigate her confused as to where
their former owner had gone this time
though there was just a box standing
outside it wasn't huge in fact it was
almost entirely empty almost picking it
up carefully in case there were baby
birds or a nest of unhatched eggs inside
Harper opened the cardboard flap to
reveal a rock sitting in the Box was a
single solitary Rock an oval of smooth
Granite with a paper note next to it
reaching in she retrieved and unfolded
the scrap please care for my pet rock
was written on one side in a messy
uncoordinated scrawl immediately
assuming that this whole thing with some
kid's idea of a joke Harper tipped the
rock out onto the ground and threw the
box in the trash she had more important
things to focus on within the next hour
alone people brought in a concussed
parakeet a bat infected with rabes and a
squirrel that had survived being run
over by a moped into the shelter work
had been so busy that by the time her
shift had ended Harper had barely
thought about the pet rock prank that is
until she was getting ready to leave she
headed through the side door mainly so
that she could do a final check in case
any animals had been left there and
someone had forgotten to hit the buzzer
there was nothing there and Harper
hooked her bag over her shoulder
shutting the door behind her something
the size and weight of a baseball
knocked against her foot causing her to
look down and see the rock the same one
from earlier only now it had flipped
over probably after she had tipped it
out of its box on the side facing up at
her the rock had a shiny metal zipper
fastened shut curious Harper picked it
up up to take a closer look it didn't
seem like the zip had just been glued
onto the Stone's surface it was embedded
in it actually part of the rock itself
and there was something sad about it
sure it was just a rock an inanimate
lump of stone but for whatever reason a
feeling of pity crept up on Harper
causing her to slip the rock into her
bag as she headed for the parking lot it
was starting to get dark by the time she
got home heading up to her room and
flipping on her lamp Harper placed the
zipped up Stone under its light and took
another long look at it although she'd
first thought it was purely a joke now
she couldn't tell if it was some
elaborate art piece or a quirky Garden
ornament the thing was solid Stone all
the way through surely the Zipper was
just for show there couldn't possibly be
anything beneath it to her surprise the
metal Fastener began to part as Harper
dragged on the puller and slider down
from the top stop towards the bottom one
one it was relatively easy not even some
of her own clothes unzipped as smoothly
as this rock as soon as the slider
connected with the bottom stop the teeth
of the top and bottom edges parted
revealing more teeth below except these
almost looked like human teeth they
opened up to reveal a mouth a part of
the rock just like the zipper which took
the place of its lips the moment the
mouth opened let out a tiny sound like
it was breathing which startled heart
with a Yelp she dropped the Rock from
her hands and it even made a tiny grunt
as it fell to the floor it was alive
seeing it hit her bedroom carpet Harper
stared utterly bewildered at the Rock
its toothy mouth almost looked sad like
it had curved into a frown then she
heard the sound it was making perhaps it
was her years working with animals at
the shelter and her long- held sympathy
for them that had given her a sort of
protective Instinct for all living
things or maybe if it was just the
bizarreness of the situation of having a
rock with a mouth whimpering in pain on
the floor in front of her either way
Harper felt compelled to pick the lump
of stone back up and place it gently on
the desk its mouth seemed to smile a bit
more as she did while it seemed creepy
at first the compulsion to take care of
this helpless Little Rock only got
stronger grabbing a pipet and pouring a
glass of water from the faucet Harper
started to squeeze out droplets of water
into the Rock's mouth she had no idea
how it was able to drink but that didn't
seem at all important or relevant in
order for her to care for it after all
every time a parrot or duck or Crow was
brought into the station the procedure
was similar Harper would have to pipet
them water or medicine it didn't matter
how they drank it just because they had
beaks it was the same with baby animals
puppies and kittens especially who might
need bottle feeding if they were only a
few weeks old as much as she was
starting from scratch and would normally
be completely completely baffled as to
the best way she could care for the Rock
right now Harper was pulling on her
experience at the shelter to nurse it
back to health if she was in fact using
her instincts and not being influenced
somehow over the next few days Harper
looked after her Newfound patient as if
it had been her lifelong pet as to why
she was taking such care of a rock or
even what she would eventually do with
it Harper didn't really have much of a
clue but the answer to those questions
didn't feel as important as looking
after the rock she'd leave for work in
the morning only to count down the hours
through her shift until she got to go
home and tend to The Smiling Stone
throughout the course of her working day
she would pocket supplies to help her
take better care of her new pet
everything from medicine in case it got
sick or picked up an infection of some
kind to bandages and other materials she
could use as Bing grabbing a fresh clean
plastic container for it instead of
another cardboard box Harper was
gradually fashioning a nest for the
toothy Pebble and for the most part it
seemed to be working some deep-seated
feeling told her that her efforts to
look after the rock was gradually making
it feel better every day and then it
started talking it wasn't exactly
articulate or eloquent it didn't even
seem to know that many words other than
the two it was weakly repeating when she
came home from work one day need eat it
rasped a horse whisper passing through
its un zipped lips rushing over to it
barely questioning it Harper tried
filling up her pipet and giving it more
water The Rock bat it back out before
speaking again no drink only
eat what what do I need to feed you she
asked only again not questioning the
absurdity of talking to a rock maybe
after this point after getting over the
fact it had a mouth it wasn't much of a
shock that the stone also had a voice or
could her compelling need to care for it
make her oblivious to the strangeness of
this situation of course this wasn't a
situation that many people had also
found themselves in this meant that even
a quick cursory internet search for what
do pet rocks eat didn't yield many
useful results only a few joke articles
and nothing that actually gave Harper an
answer she could act on all the while
her Rock was still croaking out the same
two words repeating them on a loop its
little voice getting more and more
forceful each time eat eat eat eat low
on options Harper left some bread crusts
in The Rock's Nest hoping that would be
enough to at least satiate the Rock's
obvious hunger it paused either smelling
or sensing that it had been offered
something to eat feed it rasped before
opening its mouth wide with a tiny
expectant picking up the crusts one by
one Harper broke little pieces off and
fed each bit to a rock she sighed as a
sense of overwhelming relief came FL
flooding over her glad that she'd found
a way to feed the mouthy little mineral
if only it had worked for longer only a
few hours later Harper was met with more
scraping demands from her pet rock the
insistent sound waking her up in the
middle of the night but this time as she
offered it more bread scraps it refused
to eat them it was still the early hours
of the morning by the time that Harper
had gotten through offering the rock
every different type of food in her
kitchen eventually giving up through
sheer exhaustion she folded her pillow
over her ears trying to drown out the
constant cries of me eat but it didn't
do enough to allow her to get to sleep
at any rate the feeling that she had to
care for this talking Rock was keeping
her awake as much as the noise staring
across the room purposely facing away
from her pet rock Harper's eyes fell
over her work uniform the logo of the
animal shelter stitched on it was just
about visible as the gentle glow of
Street lamps bled through the curtains
and seeing it along with her Keys
clipped onto her belt that lay on the
floor gave her an idea that might work
desperation and the need to sleep
getting the better of her Harper climbed
in the car having put a jacket and jeans
over her pajamas the streets were all
empty at this hour almost pitch dark and
deafly silent but it made driving from
her home to her workplace a lot faster
than usual all the while The Rock's
voice was getting more and more
demanding from its container that she
had strapped to the front passenger seat
sneaking up to the side door Harper
turned her key in the lock pulled it
open and slipped in doors the moment
they heard the sound of the door
shutting a number of the dogs that had
been resting securely in their cages
woke up and started barking the noise
loudly echoing around the shelter even
though it drowned Out The Rock's tiny
voice it felt as if its words were still
ringing in Harper's ears compelling her
to go through with something she really
didn't want to and yet it felt like one
of the only other options she had left
she decided it would have to be the
squirrel rationalizing the choice in her
head in an unpleasant but purely
calculated logic based way it made the
most sense earlier that week the bushy
tailed Woodland forager had been hit by
a moped it had barely survived given the
number of its tiny bones that had been
broken in the force of the impact
finding its cage it was still asleep
heavily sedated on the dosage of
painkillers the shelter's resident vet
had given it gently scooping it out of
the cage feeling its fur against her
cued hand Harper looked at her pet rock
its container on the table she
remembered that it liked to be fed
directly swallowing an urge to be sick
that was rising at the back of her
throat Harper opened a drawer in the
vet's office and pulled out a surgical
scalpel when her boss at the shelter
heard there had been a break-in and
reviewed the footage on the building
security cameras they were shocked at
what they saw though the angle obscured
what Harper was doing the blood left
over and one missing squirrel seemed to
be enough to go on that coupled with the
fact that she had broken in after hours
and the numerous supplies that had gone
missing from the storage cupboard led to
Harper being dismissed she was fired
from her job at the animal shelter
forced to hand over her keys and uniform
while any other day this would have
devastated her the events seemed to wash
over Harper pretty quickly she was more
relieved no pleased with herself that
The Rock had stopped begging her to be
fed her plan had worked for now it took
about week for her pet rock to start
demanding food again this time just the
sound of its voice made Harper frantic
any ordinary human food she offered
wasn't enough it didn't want that she
already knew exactly what it wanted the
only thing she'd fed it that had
sustained it the big problem was that
now she didn't have her keys it would be
near impossible for her to get into the
shelter again yet still the forceful
command to be fed kept up day and night
hour after hour until Harper considered
the only thing she had left to give her
pet rock lifting it out of the warm Nest
she kept it in her fingers were gripping
the smooth Stone tightly her arm was
tense in fact both were one of her
muscles strained while she held the rock
the other in anticipation hovering it
above her opposite arm Harper could feel
the tiny breaths of her pet against her
skin almost like it was so excited to
eat again that it was panting with
expectancy she put it back down on her
desk quick running into the bathroom it
wasn't that she had changed her mind she
couldn't all she knew was that she had
to feed her pet rock Harper just needed
to grab a cloth to put it in her mouth
clamping her Jaws down on it to muffle
her scream as she let the Rock's teeth
sink into her Flesh Blood trickling down
her arm nobody saw much of Harper
afterwards her friends from the shelter
would continuously call her cell phone
only to get no reply she barely paid any
attention to the ringing eventually just
letting her phone batteries die and not
even bothering to charge it back up it
wasn't important to her the only thing
that mattered was caring for her pet
rock in Harper's head it needed to be
kept safe and fed and it was her job to
look after it to the best of her ability
she had enough left over medical
supplies that she lifted from the
shelter bandages antiseptic spray
rubbing alcohol tranquilizers to treat
her wounds after a while it almost
stopped hurting knowing that she was
health and keep her pet rock fed being
so emotionally attached to it made all
of the pain more bearable even when she
woke up one morning to find that her
Rock had rolled off her desk onto her
bed it hardly phased her nor did seeing
that it had gradually eaten her leg
during the night gnawing through tendons
and bone as she slept leaving her Sheets
still slick with blood when she awoke
despite having lost most of her capacity
for rational thought Harper decided it
would be best to plan ahead for when she
was gone she knew through through some
Twisted form of logic that she wasn't
going to last forever there was only so
much of her she'd be able to feed her
pet rock for so long Harper held a pen
in her hand as best she could with all
the fingers she was now missing she
scrolled out a note to herever found
what was left of her in messy
uncoordinated handwriting please care
for my pet rock not everything in this
world is exactly as it seems in fact
there are many creatures in the wild
that go out of their way to be deceptive
to disguise themselves as something
entirely different from their true
nature aggressive mimicry refers to a
phenomenon in which Predators or
parasites take on the appearance of
something harmless or even appealing in
order to lure in their intended prey or
host without detection they might
resemble food an inanimate part of the
environment or even a potential mate
whatever they choose they're secretly a
wolf in sheep's clothing in in the deep
dark Waters of the ocean the angler fish
dangles an alluring light from its head
ushering in little fish that it can trap
in its mouth and devour whole the
alligator snapping turtle Wiggles its
long tongue like a worm attracting
Hungry Fish looking for their next meal
instead they become the meal for
something bigger and more clever than
them false cleaner fish share their
appearance of another species one that
helps clean larger fish in a symbiotic
relationship when the imposters find a
VI them they swim close under the
pretense of cleaning only to take a bite
out of them and swim away Predators use
similar illusions on land 2 anti-
mimicking jumping spiders wave their
false antenna in the air in an imitation
of an ant's movements isolating the
insects from their colony before
dragging them back to their Lair to be
devoured the mouth parts of the male
spiders are shaped like the head of an
ant but this imitation head splits apart
to reveal the spider's fangs and it's
true intentions the furus Firefly lights
up its body in a mimicry of other
Firefly species mating signals signaling
male fireflies looking for companionship
when they respond to the call however
they will not find a willing mate
waiting but instead a fem fatal of a
firefly that just wants to eat the
spider-tailed horn Viper has a bulbous
tip on its tail with false legs jutting
out on either side as the snake Wiggles
its tail running it across the ground
while the rest of its body lies in just
out of sight a hungry bird spots it from
above when the bird swoops down to seize
the opportunity the snake reveals itself
snapping up the unfortunate bird before
it can escape thankfully humans are so
much smarter and more observant than
fish ants and birds we're safe from that
sort of trickery there aren't any
animals out there who've learned how to
look like something familiar something
every day just to put unsuspecting
people at ease and lure us into its
waiting Jaws right wrong long only a
couple of years ago the SCP Foundation
discovered a being that has mastered
aggressive mimicry on a level previously
unseen in the natural world
unfortunately for us its prey of choice
happens to be humans and its hunting
ground is the very cities where we like
to think we're safe from something much
bigger meaner and hungrier than us a
short video went viral on a popular
social media platform the specific
platform has been redacted from official
files but the details of it are clear a
popular Creator on the app a young woman
known for her makeup tutorials and
restaurant recommendations around her
native city of Los Angeles she was live
streaming and answering questions while
going about her day when she stepped
onto a train at one of the Metro
stations around the city the train was
extremely crowded and she was preparing
to end the live video planning to resume
once she reached her destination but
just as she went to press the button at
the end of the stream something strange
happened the train went dark and the
space flooded with a strange thick
liquid the girl screamed in either pain
horror or both and dropped the phone
whatever it fell into must have degraded
the phone at an extremely rapid Pace
because the video feed cut out
immediately after a splash all across
social media people shared the video
with one question in mind what happened
on that train fans mounted a campaign to
find the influencer to help her if she
was in any immediate danger but there
were no leads her friends and family
said she never came home that day and
when authorities attempted to trace her
phone they could not get any kind of
signal becoming increasingly concerned
about this missing girl and the
possibility of some kind of unreported
train accident authorities contacted the
Los Angeles metro and showed them the
video footage but every train was
accounted for and in pristine condition
there had been no strange chemical leaks
no crashes and certainly nothing like
what the video appeared to show at the
same time there were were missing
persons reports being filed all across
the country in every area with a
thriving public transportation system
not only were the occupants of the Los
Angeles train unaccounted for with no
wreckage or bodies to be found but
people were disappearing in train
stations in New York Boston Chicago
Washington DC and more a woman reported
her husband missing after he called her
to check in during his daily commute
home from work the train had kept going
for much longer than it ordinarily did
drifting off of its usual route he told
her that something was wrong that he had
a terrible feeling of for boing and then
the call cut off he never made it home
for dinner a young woman was on her way
to start an internship at a prestigious
New York City magazine but never arrived
for her first meeting when her wouldbe
boss reached out to the girl's roommate
all he knew was that she had planned to
take the train to work that morning a
private detective trailing a man's wife
for him looking for evidence of an
affair lost track of her when she
stepped onto a train downtown he took
the next train hoping to catch her at
what he assumed would be her stop but
she never got off he wasn't able to
track her down and had to give her
suspicious husband the news that his
wife had somehow vanished Into Thin Air
it wasn't just one or two people every
so often either entire train cars of
people were just disappearing never to
be seen again no matter how hard anyone
tried they could not find any answers no
logical explanation for what could
happened fortunately the video
circulated so widely that it made it
onto the feed of an SCP Foundation
employee who was idly scrolling during a
bathroom break he was so shocked by what
he saw that he almost forgot to pull up
his pants before running out into the
Hall fortunately he did remember and
rushed to his supervisor's office fully
clothed after determining that the video
was not a hoax or some kind of viral
marketing stun intended to sell a new
brand of spicy chips the SCP Foundation
decided to launch a formal investig
ation into anomalous activity involving
trains and subway systems around the
country task forces were set up in every
major city and field researchers were
assigned to take the train all day every
day as much as possible as they did they
would maintain communication with the
head of their task force would monitor
their findings via hidden cameras and
microphones a week passed without
incident and the foundation was starting
to wonder if somehow the Los Angeles
video had been fate when the Chicago
task force made a harrowing Discovery
officer Jamie Bower was assigned to
monitor the trains on Chicago's Blue
Line taking the train throughout the day
and keeping an eye out for suspicious or
potentially anomalous Activity one week
in and he pretty much had it down to a
basic routine he would grab breakfast
hop on the train and enjoy his coffee
and meal while reading a book and
writing the train to its last stop then
he'd pick up lunch and do the same thing
all over again he'd have dinner and
repeat it wasn't too exciting but then
again excitement in in this case
probably meant Horrors Beyond his
comprehension so he was perfectly fine
with traversing the city in a subway car
and catching up on the backlog of murder
mysteries he'd been meaning to read it
was Monday afternoon he'd picked up a
slice of deep dish pizza excited to try
it for the first time and walked down
into the metro station as he took his
first bite can you try not to chew into
your microphone please it's gross Dr
Susan Shephard the head of the Chicago
task force spoke into Jam's earpiece you
got it boss he said his mouth full
thanks see anything unusual today she
asked you tell me you can see the video
feed right he took another bite chewing
as quietly as he could sure but you're
on the ground just keep an eye out okay
be careful remember to draw your weapon
if something goes south don't just
disappear into your book and forget to
keep your wits about you Dr Shephard
sighed yep getting on the train now not
going to talk much so these folks don't
think I'm nuts Jamie waited for the
doors to open and just for a moment
noticed that they seem seemed to stick
just a little this time nothing to be
too worried about though everything
looked normal just as it had on every
other ride he' taken he could feel the
Agatha chrisy book calling to him from
inside of his tote bag and he wanted to
crack it open and see what Clues heru
quo had come across but Dr Shephard was
right he'd been slacking off he needed
to pay attention to his surroundings so
he did just that he watched as the train
car steadily filled up with passengers
college students with bags full of books
and exhausted Expressions middle-aged
people in business attire tourists
wearing souvenir baseball caps and
snapping pictures of everything in sight
before too long the train was completely
packed and Jamie could barely move
without bumping elbows with someone it
was a little claustrophobic but that was
public transportation jime leaned back
in his seat pulled his book out and
focused on the comforting Rumble of the
engine the Rhythm Of The Wheels On The
Tracks suddenly without warning the
train screeched to a step stop they were
in the middle of a tunnel Jamie assumed
from the darkness that flanked them out
the window on either side wait was it
dark or the windows just disappeared he
squinted through the Blackness and tried
to see what was outside but he couldn't
make sense of his surroundings all
around the other passengers were
becoming Restless nervous some were
calling for help others were just
complaining doc you seeing this Jamie
hissed into the microphone I don't see a
thing Dr Shephard replied are you all
right fine the Train's just stalled I
don't know where or what's wrong with it
Jamie began feeling along the walls of
the train looking for doors huh that's
weird what well the crack in the doors
when they come together should be right
here but it's all smooth no gaps or
anything like it's all one thing and it
feels strange like he cut himself off as
his stomach dropped a sudden Rush of
fear flooding his senses like what Dr
Shephard pressed like it's alive Jamie
said shakely Campbell what's happening
in there Dr Shepard began taking Furious
notes on her hand I don't know it's so
dark everyone's scared I'm scared I
don't think this is a train I don't know
what it is but it's nothing good as
Jamie felt around he smelled something
sour foul and sharp in his nose he heard
liquid splashing onto the ground the
sound of something sizzling and then
people started to scream as he felt
along the wall something dripped onto
his hand and then it started to burn he
cried out in agony as whatever had
dripped onto him ate away at the skin
dissolving his hand bit by bit what is
it Dr Shephard's voice shook as she
heard the pain in Jim's voice some kind
of acid oh God it's everywhere it's on
the walls floors it just keeps coming he
trailed off oh God oh God we're in his
stomach whatever this thing is it's
eating us Campbell you need to get out
of there right now Dr shepher ordered
draw your weapon whatever you need to do
just get out Jamie pulled out his weapon
and started firing at the place where
the doors should be but the bullets
bounced off uselessly as if the fleshy
material was the side of a tank he fired
until there was no more ammunition left
and then he just kept squeezing the
trigger some more out of pure survival
Instinct but all it got him was a
useless click and the certainty that the
one thing he had brought with him in
case of emergency was completely useless
all the while the acid was creeping
higher dripping from every surface
filling the train car until it swallowed
the cries for help and the screams of
fear and Agony all Dr Shepard could do
was listen helpless as Jamie and the
rest of the passengers were digested
inside of the massive stomach what
happened to officer Jamie Campbell was
tragic but it provided important
information that the foundation would
likely never have gotten otherwise they
now knew a few key things about this new
anomaly it was some kind of living thing
able to disguise itself as a train it
was resilient to bullets and firearms
and it was hiding in plain sight in
order to hunt human beings they had
found the culprit for the rash of
mysterious disappear appearances and it
was a race of unidentified creatures
capable of taking on the shape of a
common underground train the new found
information quickly circulated
throughout the foundation making its way
to the various task forces assigned to
operation Metro as it had been
unofficially nicknamed task force
members were no longer instructed to
board trains instead they would slip
hidden cameras onto as many train cars
as they possibly could each outfitted
with a tracking device then the
foundation could remotely monitor the
trains for any potential signs of the
mysterious creatures looking for
imposters masquerading as trains without
unnecessarily losing any more operatives
in action now as for what they would do
once they found one of these massive
creatures was still uncertain but at
least they had somewhere to start the
SCP Foundation tried and failed to
contain several instances of the
carnivorous species before they finally
got it right they attempted to freeze
the inside of one train with liquid
nitrogen hoping to incapacitate the
creature before it could could feed
defend itself or Escape custody the
extreme cold seemed to have no effect
however and the false train slammed its
doors shut at the first sign of
discomfort then sped away at high speed
as it did the task force members noticed
that though they could hear the sound of
wheels on the tracks they could see legs
jutting out of the bottom of the
creature scuttling along the ground next
they attempted to take out the creatur's
legs and render it immobile so that it
could be subdued the legs were resilient
to external damage becoming hard as a
rock whenever any weapon blade or other
Implement made contact with them one
Task Force member tried to physically
hold some of the legs in place but they
shifted their shape becoming appendages
resembling tentacles and threw the man
out of the way before the false train
hurried out of the tunnel and out of
sight they were then able to track down
a predatory train just after a feeding
when it was slightly sluggish after a
large meal they pumped an aerosolized
poison into the Train's interior the
belly of the Beast potent enough to take
take out a dinosaur and were relieved to
find that the creature was unable to
flee unfortunately though they were able
to subdue the creature they killed it in
the process at first they assumed it was
just inactive but it never resumed
activity again it was just like an
ordinary train car almost when the
interior was touched it felt warm and
slightly pliable less like metal and
plastic and more like flesh the longer
the creature was still the more the
windows on the side stopped looking like
windows and started looking like wide
glassy eyes the front of the train
became a gaping maw the silhouette of
the conductor inside revealed as an
extension of the creature's body
resembling a tongue survivors and
Witnesses were given an amnestic to
remove any memories of the supposed
killer trains running under their city
and the foundation prepared to bring the
dead specimen in for further study a
cover story was used involving massive
repairs to the train system and while
the tunnels were closed off they managed
to remove the creature and transported
to a nearby Foundation containment site
there it was given one of the most
extensive autopsies in Foundation
history and the first one conducted
largely from inside the subject the
autopsy provided a more in-depth look at
the nature of the bizarre creature and
its curious nature the creature
nicknamed the train eater referring to
its preferred disguise and favored
activity was one of an apparent species
of carnivorous predators that use
shape-shifting and an advanced form of
aggressive mimicry to prey on commuters
tourists and anyone else in need of a
ride from one place to the next it would
mimic the shape feel and sounds of a
train welcoming unassuming victims into
its stomach and once it was completely
full and able to efficiently feed it
would release an incredibly potent
stomach acid into the compartment and
quickly dissolve everything inside the
creature was highly adaptable able to
harden parts of its body at will and
display extreme resilience to weapons of
any kind
due to this nearly impenetrable flesh
victims trapped inside would be unable
to force their way out as the research
staff turned in their autopsy results
and official report there was a sense of
unease in the air as everyone wondered
how many of these things are out there
which innocent trip to work might be
their last and how on Earth could they
hope to contain something that could
exist in endless numbers something so
expert at hiding in plain sight there
was no realistic way to to bring all
these creatures into custody and so they
would have to neutralize as many as
possible without being detected
Foundation operatives embedded in
various city and state governments
introduced new measures to renovate
public transportation systems including
new sanitation protocols as part of
these protocols all trains would be
sprayed with a high strength
disinfectant before they could be
certified for use in reality this
disinfectant would be the same poison
used to take down the first train eater
the foundation studied once any and all
potent threats had been rendered
harmless trains that were found to be
formally living would be converted into
fully functioning trains and allowed to
run as normal in order to avoid
unnecessary interruptions to the public
in addition to these containment
measures the foundation monitors all
social media for mentions of unusual
activity on trains or mentions of any
more missing persons lost at Metro
stations the original Los Angeles video
that started it all was scrubbed from
the internet entirely so by all means
take advantage of your local public
transportation options but remain
Vigilant and keep your wits about you
and remember next time you travel by
train if you see something say something
more specifically if you see something
unusual on a train if it looks a little
different than it did yesterday if its
sounds don't seem quite right make sure
to let everyone around you know that it
is not safe to be here and quickly make
your way to the exit then maybe walk to
your destination instead it might make
you a little bit late but hey better
late than dinner we all have fond
memories of the playground hours upon
hours spent in Blissful childhood
abandon racing around the local park
climbing the monkey bars and seeing if
you could get even higher on the swings
than your best friend and then of course
there's the slide who doesn't love a
slide only you and the force of gravity
pulling you down through a straight or
spiral tube those few seconds of
excitement that Rush of not knowing
whether you'll come out the other end of
the slide or not that's enough of a
thrill for any kid of course you would
always come tumbling out of the mouth
with a slide every time at worst with an
odd but innocent friction burn on your
leg or arm but what if one day you
didn't come out of the other end or
Worse what if the place at the end of
the slide wasn't the world you left
behind when you slid through the
entrance it doesn't seem seem all that
likely to happen right well you've
obviously never taken a trip down SCP
1562 better known as the tunnel slide as
its moniker suggests SCP 1562 is a slide
or it at least appears to be an ordinary
tunnel slide you know the kind that you
would easily find at any kids park
jungle gym or indoor play area just over
2 m high and almost 3 and 1/2 M long and
for the most most part it is a
completely normal slide if you were to
just sit in it and glide down it feet
first nothing would happen then again if
SCP 1562 was an ordinary everyday piece
of a playground then the SCP Foundation
would not have such a vested interest in
it they definitely wouldn't be keeping
it locked up in quarantine secured in
Testing Lab 46- V of site 24 and if any
foundation agents ask you didn't hear
that from Us by the way the door to the
lab is kept locked at all times no
member of personnel is even allowed near
the slide unless granted special
clearance to do so by Foundation
researcher Dr Carver so what is it that
makes this thing so special well for one
SCP 1562 was first recovered by the
foundation from a defunct abandoned
playground the location of this
playground has been redacted but it was
known to be on the outskirts of a town
where a number of young children had
been reported missing does SCP 1562
contain some sort of clue as to where
these children were taken perhaps some
piece of forensic evidence left behind
by a child snatching anomaly From
Another Dimension not quite SCP 1562 is
the thing that took those children you
see the slides anomalous properties
require very specific circumstances in
order to activate like we mentioned
earlier if you were just sitting on your
butt while you were sliding down it you
would Escape unscathed laying flat on
your back that is also a safe option
even flailing yourself about spinning
and rolling and waving your arms
changing position on the way down would
mean that nothing anomalous would appear
to happen however if someone enters SCP
1562 and travels down in head first
laying on their stomach with their arms
tucked at their side almost in a plank
position then that is when strange
things start to happen that is when a
person finds out what happened to those
missing children only about 15 cm from
the opening of the slide a person
sliding down on their front head first
With Arms by their sides will disappear
right before exiting SCP
1562 in an instant they will simply be
gone no longer in the slide or even
relocated to anywhere nearby to make
matters worse every single person that
this has happened to has never been
found again they literally have vanished
off the face of the Earth unfortunately
there isn't much that can be done to
prevent this during testing the
foundation quickly learned that
tethering a safety line to a subject do
little to stop them from disappearing
they cannot be pulled back from wherever
it is that the slide sends them the Rope
they are attached to is simply cut and
goes slack from the moment that a person
is taken by the slide now that sounds
like the whole story right children are
going missing and the foundation learns
it's because of SCP
1562 some kind of interdimensional
portal within a playground slide so they
acquire the slide take it away and keep
it locked up securely where it can't
cause any more disappearances end of
story except that's not quite the end no
the one thing it's still possible to do
once someone has disappeared down the
slide is to stay in contact with them
the SCP Foundation has expended a number
of test subjects by sending them sliding
down SCP 1562 just to learn what's on
the other side side just where does the
slide take them luckily tests like this
are precisely what the foundation has
d-class Personnel for so what happened
when the foundation sent some DCL
classes on a one-way joy ride down the
slide well one test involved a d-class
designated
d2445 who disappeared into SCP 1562 but
was given a two-way radio to communicate
directly with Dr darrs one of the
research staff d2445 reported that he
felt himself in a small cramp tunnel and
quickly requested to be let back out Dr
jarretts had neglected to tell d2445
that was impossible and that no one ever
came back from inside the slide while it
was too dark to see anything The
Prisoner described still being laid on
his front but feeling like there were
rocks or dirt surrounding him on all
sides realizing that he barely had
enough room to move or even lift his
head d2445 again requested to be let out
of SCP 1562 as the unfortunate d-class
grew increasingly more unsettled by the
movement restricting environment Dr
derrett revealed that the lifeline
tethering d2445 back to the foundation
had been severed upon their
disappearance into the slide panicking
d2445 managed to move forward slightly
and realized that his head had hit
something a shoe a tiny child's shoe
communication with d2445 was called to a
halt and the foundation's researchers
discussed possible ways that they could
retrieve the prisoner although most of
them probably knew at this point that
this task was likely impossible this
test may have taken place before the
foundation realized that return from SCP
1562 was impossible the plan was that
another d-class would be sent into the
slide once again they would be attached
to a tether line and be carrying video
and audio recording equipment along with
the GPS tracker and a headlamp reaching
out to d2445 Dr darrett relayed this
plan to him d2445 immediately begged to
be set free from SCP 1562 as the doctor
attempted to calm him down but to little
a fact something had scared him truly
terrified him a sound coming from
somewhere within the tunnel it it
started talking d2445 claimed when Dr
darrett asked for clarity the d-class
replied saying that a little boy had
tried to speak to him but that the child
had made made little sense he just kept
asking where he was and I told him I
didn't know but I don't think he was
really talking to me because he didn't
respond my voice and he told me to stop
crying when I was actually sort of calm
when asked if this child had moved at
all d2445 said that he was unsure he
started screaming and I told him to shut
up but he just kept screaming and crying
and asking for his mommy and then he
finally stopped and shortly after that
you contacted me again please get me out
now Dr derrett tried to reassure the man
to little Avail and communication with
d2445 was cut off after he claimed
something was wrong with his chest
shortly after the foundation lost
communication with
d2445 another member of d-class was sent
into the slide after him this subject
referred to officially as D 8600 had
been specifically selected for this task
thanks to his small stature Dr darrett
and the other Foundation researchers
testing SCP 1562 believed that the man's
thinner body type would allow d86 to
better navigate the tunnel that the
slides seemed to transport people to and
you can probably guessed what happened
next just like all the others that had
been sent down the slide d86 was trapped
his Lifeline was cut the moment that he
vanished inside the tunnel slide on top
of this the GPS tracker that this
thinner d-class had been issued with
seemed to not be working properly its
signal could not be correctly traced and
without without an accurate fix there
was no way to determine the location to
which SCP 1562 was transporting its
victims if it was even in this universe
Additionally the video feed from the
camera d86 hundred was carrying also
failed to connect with only audio from
his radio being recovered by the
research team contacting
d86 Dr darrett was informed by this new
d-class that his headlamp had stopped
working the second he had arrived in the
same cave or tunnel as earlier test
subject
before long by shimmying through the
area on his arms d86 bumped into a foot
believed to be belonging to
d2445 while he could barely see anything
D 8600 could hear
d2445 voice and this was being faintly
picked up via His Radio however as he
and Dr darrett tried to talk to the
first prisoner his words began to sound
all too familiar I don't know some sort
of very small tunnel it's really cramped
can you get me out now followed by no
it's it's too dark I can't see anything
and I'm stuck it was all just a
recording from what
d2445 had said when he first arrived
after SCP 1562 had sent him into the
tunnel D 8600 did not realize this at
first and attempted to help his fellow
prisoner hoping to pull him out of
wherever they were trapped Dr darrs
tried desperately to explain that d2445
was just repeating his half of an
earlier conversation but d D 8600 hardly
noticed that was the case he gripped the
other DCL class's ankles and told the
doctor to pull them out of the tunnel
the doctor revealed that once again the
tether line had been severed but d86
refused to believe that escape was
impossible he tried to worm his way back
the way he had come leaving d2445 still
repeating his words from earlier he just
kept asking me where he was and I told
him I didn't know but I don't think he
was really talking to me because he
didn't respond to my voice and he told
me to stop crying when I was actually
sort of calm I don't think so he started
screaming and I told him to shut up but
he kept just screaming and crying and
asking for his mommy then he finally
stopped and shortly after that you
contacted me again please get me out now
please hurry my chest is really starting
to hurt after yelling at him to stop
talking multiple times d86 noted that
d2445 had finally gone quiet the d-class
also remarked that the air was starting
to taste stale and hoped that there
would be enough oxygen for him to get
back then just like his predecessor
communication with d86 came to an abrupt
stop Dr darrett was no longer able to
reach him on the radio there was nothing
but static the foundation was unable to
reestablish contact with either of the
two d-class Personnel lost inside SCP
1562 and any future testing of the
tunnel slide was suspended to this day
none of us know what exactly happened to
the victims of the tunnel slide where
were they taken what had taken them what
was making the prior victims repeat
their ominous words as horror author
Stephen King once put it it's the
unanswered questions that stays with us
the longest but the next time you decide
to Thrill your inner child by taking a
jean to your local Kitty Park you may
just find out for yourself ask anyone
that has been through it and they'll all
tell you the same that moving home is
maybe one of the most stressful things
that a normal person can ever experience
it's a logistical night right from the
start the moment you talk to a realitor
about being interested in selling your
current house and buying another
everything goes downhill from there
after that moment an avalanche of things
comes hurling towards you finding a
place you like making an offer letting
people look around your house waiting
for them to make a counter offer
exchanging contracts and that's before
you even have thought about packing and
as Milo had learned doing all of that on
your own only makes the stress of moving
feel all the more potent but he had
finally made it after a constant back
and forth with his realator the time had
come for him to pack up all of his
worldly possessions and relocate to a
brand new place to call home he had felt
it was long overdue for him to get a
change of scenery and luckily just the
right place had come onto the market to
answer that call it was a pretty big
house bigger than Milo's previous home
but considerably cheaper in fact he
thought it had been significantly
undervalued the house had an almost
Victorian a of feel to it all
beautifully carved and varnished
Woodwork and creaky old floorboards but
in more of an elegant refined sort of
way rather than a creepier one that's
not to say Milo's new place wasn't
without its more unsettling elements
aside from being big spacious and easy
to imagine as being haunted the
creepiest thing about the house aside
from its frighteningly low price was the
story of what happened to the previous
owners obviously you know that legal Al
we have to disclose whether or not
anyone died on this property the
realator had explained wearing a force
grin as she showed Milo around the house
hearing that sentence he could feel the
hairs on the back of his neck stand up
someone died here he asked in disbelief
no no no no of course not sir the
realator instantly walked back her
statement Less in an effort to ease her
client's nerves but more to ensure that
she still closed the deal and earned her
commission bonus then why the hell would
you start a sent like that Milo asked we
just have to give full disclosure but I
assure you the previous residents didn't
die on the grounds of this house she
gave that fake smile again it was pretty
ineffectual at reassuring him so what
happened to the last owner well it's a
bit of a mystery to be honest a local
Legend if you like but hey that gives
the place more flavor hearing some
spooky history right think of what a
conversation starter that will be the
realator ended her sentence with a
forced snorting laugh laugh but rained
it back in when she realized Milo wasn't
laughing with her ah as far as I know
there used to be an older couple living
here the Shaws they were apparently very
quiet reclusive kept to themselves a lot
I'm sure you know the type Milo couldn't
help but notice she shot him a look as
she said that part as if she was
silently passing judgment on the fact he
was planning on moving in alone but they
used to spend a lot of time tending the
garden out front so their neighbors
would see them pretty frequently which
meant they were all okay and no one had
any bad mishaps in the house you know
how old folks can be such a worry when
they get to that age yeah totally Milo
interjected aware the realator was
stalling he repeated so what actually
happened to them well that's the thing
she Shrugged Nobody Knows the full story
one day the neighbors across the street
noticed they hadn't seen Mr and Mrs Shaw
for quite a while so naturally they came
on over here to see if they were in and
the last thing they wanted was to assume
everything was was hunky dory here I
mean hey better save them sorry right
but once they got inside they couldn't
find either of them Mr and Mrs Shaw were
just gone vanished Without a Trace most
people on the street thought they had
just sold the place kept it quiet and
moved away retired to somewhere nice and
exotic Oh well that sounds nice I
suppose Milo replied relieved to hear
that there hadn't been any brutal
unsolved murders in the house and that
it most likely wasn't haunted that's
just what the neighbors think anyway the
real continued of course they hadn't
sold the house they just left it when my
firm came in to repossess the place it
had all their belongings in it some
might even still be laying around here
anyway did you want to have a look at
that contract well strictly speaking
Milo was the only human living in his
new house he was never fully alone he
had arrived with his two closest friends
a pair of pets he had adopted while
living in his old house one was a
hamster by the name of donut named after
his round little body and the golden
brown shade of his his fur had reminded
Milo of the glaze sugary baked treat the
other was Pixel a bearded dragon with a
pattern on his scales that resembled
some kind of mosaic art the first order
of business Milo had decided was before
even unpacking he needed to make sure
his scaly and furry friends each had a
suitable place to stay and that he got
them fed little did he realize there was
something else living in the house with
them something that was Far bigger and
was getting much hungrier than either of
his pets would looking around the house
Milo stumbled across a few boxes that he
hadn't brought with him like the realtor
had said the shaw still had some of
their possessions left lying around the
place most of it was useless to Milo old
man's clothes or a set of knitting
needles and rolls of colorful thread it
was those particular clues that seemed
to imply Mrs Shaw had a lot of free time
on her hands and maybe took up knitting
as a hobby during retirement of course
the bigger clue was the huge handmade
blanket that Milo found draped over some
of the remaining boxes in the Attic he
wasn't exactly well versed in knitwear
but he could appreciate the craft behind
this soft blanket it clearly had a lot
of time and effort put into making it
painstakingly knitting each and every
individual thread looping it around a
pair of Steel needles and eventually
after hours of wearing out shaking bony
fingers produce something that actually
looked quite nice even though the idea
of sitting and knitting a blanket might
have been one of the most boring uses of
time Milo could imagine he still had to
admit he was surprised that the Shaws
had left this particular piece of
bedding behind it seemed like it would
be pretty comfy to sleep under it might
help keep a person warm at night now
that the colder seasons were approaching
what's more was that the blanket was
clean almost like it had been freshly
washed there was no old person smell on
it no dirt or discoloration not a stain
and it hadn't even accumulated any dust
in its fibers in fact he noticed that
there was hardly any dust at all up in
the attic despite the house being empty
for so long he assumed the realators had
hired someone As a caretaker while they
found a buyer for the place and they had
kept the place clean after all what
other conclusion could they have
possibly drawn it's not as if something
had eaten all the dust that would be
absurd he'd have a sort through of the
Shaw's leftovers later maybe sell some
of it off at a local yard sale or give
it to a thrift store but that blanket
might come in handy when it started
snowing so Milo had half a mind to keep
it now part of what makes moving home
such a stressful life experience isn't
just all the logistical and
administrative parts of the process it's
only made worse by the fact that it
takes forever to move into a new house
fully that's the part everyone always
forgets about the months after a move
when you're forced to live amongst
towers of cardboard boxes all your
worldly possessions bury deep within
them and you can never remember which
crate anything is in when you urgently
need it so realizing it would take him
much longer to unpack all of his things
Milo set about making sure he had
everything that donut and pixel would
need already to hand the latter of his
two Pets the bearded dragon usually
spent most of his days in a spacious
glass tank Milo didn't love the idea of
keeping either of his two best buds so
confined but pixel never went very far
anyway content to lay under a heat lamp
almost perfectly still for most of the
day donut on the other hand and was much
more of a free spirit the tiny brown
hamster physically could not stay still
and most a seemed to be filled with more
energy than Milo was as a result he let
the little guy roll about inside a
little plastic ball all day long until
his little hamster feet gave out and now
donut had much more space to zip around
inside his ball so while he entertained
himself Milo could focus on what needed
fixing cleaning and generally improving
around the house it didn't take him long
to realize however that the reals had
pulled a bit of a fast one on him
despite the absolute steal of a price
that Milo had been offered it quickly
became clear that the unknown fate of
the previous residence wasn't the only
detail about the house that had been
conveniently kept hidden the place was
in dire need of repair with a lot of the
old woodwork rapidly rotting away if
left unchecked parts of the house could
collapse and come apart at the seams to
make matters worse the boiler was an
ancient iron monstrosity that was barely
able to produce warm water
which would quickly become an even
bigger problem when the weather started
to get colder then to top off the
trifecta of unforeseen issues and
teething problems with his new place
Milo couldn't sleep it was to be
expected after all the house was old
worn out and had definitely seen better
days there were bound to be a few noises
the odd Creek coming from upstairs when
Milo and his two pets were all
downstairs the tapping of branches
against Windows blowing in the wind
outside but for some reason every
Audible disturbance that emanated from
some hidden corner of the building only
seemed to get a thousand times louder
when the sun went down at nighttime
every squeaky floorboard or random noise
of the house settling was nearly
deafening enough to pull Milo right out
of what little Restless sleep he was
getting the worst part about it was
though he couldn't help it it made him
feel unwelcome as if Mr and Mrs Shaw
were angered that he had moved in in the
dark it was hard not to picture every
sound as one or both of the old couple
creeping through the corridors coming to
reclaim their home and remove Milo from
the premises one night the noises
started invading what little sleep Milo
did manage to get spilling into his
dream and causing them to devolve into
unsettling nightmares there was an old
photograph in a frame that he had come
across in the personal effects left
behind by the Shaws showing the pair of
them staring disapprovingly out of the
image at him now thanks to the creaking
wooden structure of the house and the
sounds it made at at night Milo was
seeing the old couple in every bad dream
he had both their faces were locked in
those same still frozen expressions of
contempt as they tried to exercise him
like an interloper on their property
that was the final nail on the coffin
that made Milo realize he needed to look
at other options surely there had to be
some way to induce a deep enough sleep
so that the sounds the house was making
weren't keeping him up or incepting
nightmares anymore he called the local
doctor arranging a consultation for
later that day as he hung up the phone
something nudged against his foot it was
donut having rolled through the Maze of
cardboard boxes still filling the house
Milo took one look at the little brown
furred hamster then the crates that
still littered the place grabbing the
leftover items that the shots had
forgotten to take with them before they
vanished Milo moved those boxes out into
the shed he knew he was probably
reaching that it was hard likely to make
even the slightest difference to his
sleeping but maybe keeping their stuff
away from him would keep the old couple
out of his head the only thing he kept
in the house was the blanket there was
no use letting it go to waste especially
knowing that the boiler was on the blink
and it would be cold soon he rolled it
up and left it on his bed leaving his
more mobile pet in the same room before
heading out to see the doctor when Milo
got back a bottle of prescription
sleeping pills in his pocket he couldn't
help but notice his room seemed
different the blanket looked like it had
fallen off the bed and onto the the
floor for one but more worryingly
Donut's plastic travel ball had been
split open laying in pieces on the
ground with its furly little occupant
nowhere to be seen over the next few
hours Milo searched every corner of the
house calling out to his hamster trying
to lure it back with more morsels of
food but donut didn't seem to be
anywhere he wasn't even underneath the
knitted blanket still there was no sign
as worry set in Milo hurly checked
pixel's cage to see if he was gone too
but the lizard was relaxing as lethargic
as ever completely unfazed by what was
going on it certainly seemed that when
it rained it really poured in this new
house just as he was searching for his
missing hamster Milo heard a new
horrible sound echo through the
corridors this one wasn't so much a
scary noise even if it did make him jump
but it was more the inconvenience that
came with it finally giving out after
God knows how many years it had been
installed for The house's boiler burned
first spending the afternoon into the
evening failing to track down one of his
Missing Pets and stopping the huge
ironcast boiler from flooding the
basement wasn't exactly what Milo had in
mind for fun activities to do when he
got home going to bed frustrated made it
as hard to sleep as all the nightly
cacophony of creaking floorboards and
branches raking against the windows he
tapped out two of the pills the doctor
had prescribed him knocking them back
with a sharp motion of his head and a
swig of cold water before laying back
back in bed as night had fallen the
temperature also had plummeted too and
not having a boiler to heat his room
meant that Milo couldn't stop himself
from shivering in the cold his breath
forming clouds in front of his face he
reached for the knitted blanket and
threw it over himself curling up
underneath it to try and provide an
extra layer of warmth to protect himself
from the gnawing cold the pills did as
they were meant to helping Milo to
quickly sleep into a much deeper sleep
than he had experienced in a while
although it didn't seemed to help the
nightmares Mr and Mrs Shaw came back
again this time they had Milo's arms and
legs tied up with their matching
disapproving faces the elderly couple
threw something over their helpless
victim and tried to smother him to death
for a dream it felt so intense so real
Milo could feel a heavy weight on top of
his body as he slept in fact it felt
like it was all around him engulfing and
crushing the life out of him from all
sides but it was the feeling of
something wet against his arm the
sensation of liquid against his skin and
the numbness where his hands should be
were what finally pulled him out of the
dream and into the nightmare through the
dark and his cloudy vision Milo could
see a wide gaping ma filled with teeth
the feeling of being crushed was still
surrounding him and despite kicking his
legs and trying to free himself from
confinement it didn't stop squeezing him
tighter his Panic was already making it
harder to catch his breath but now he
could barely fill his lungs enough to
scream for help not that anyone was
around to hear him but it was the side
of his arm that chilled Milo's blood it
wasn't there anymore part of it just
above the elbow was just gone his hand
fingers every internal bone and muscle
had been reduced to a bloody mess a
slurry of red melting and coming apart
it was runny little more than a liquid
resembling the consistency of sand when
it's underwater and BEC sludge most of
his flesh was liquefied going further up
his arm and as the blanket pulled its
prey into its mouth until Milo was no
more not a trace of him left just like
the previous owners little did Milo or
the Shaws and donut before him know but
he'd been the victim of a creature that
was part of a rather unique species well
they will often vary in size shape
pattern and other aspects of their
appearance SCP 799 always seemed to be
ordinary items of knitted bedwear at
least at first they retain heat like a
normal blanket wood and are soft to the
touch and for for the most part don't
seem directly harmful and usually they
aren't SCP 799 are incapable of much
movement instead laying still a lot of
time not unlike a certain bearded dragon
that just lost its owner they also don't
seem to require much in the way of food
extracting what little nutrition they do
need by drawing in household dust a lot
of the organic matter and dust is
comprised of dead and discarded human
hair and skin cells so this makes sense
this feeding is all done through
filtered m mouths in the fibers however
this changes if an SCP 799 blanket is
forced to go on a long time without food
will they possess this biological trait
themselves SCP 799 don't seem to regard
cold-blooded animals to be the source of
food in fact they don't even seem to be
able to detect other creatures with cold
blood such as reptiles instead as CP 799
will metamorphose into a more predatory
form in order to consume any warm
blooded mammal or human being it
encounters transforming its feeding
orifices and digestive tract into a
singular mouth lined with several rolls
of sharp pointed teeth from there it
will wrap up the largest warm-blooded
animal it can find whether that be a
hamster or a grown man and will tear off
parts of its prey reducing them to
little more than a thin slurry as it
digests their body mass to feet itself
so if you move into a new house and come
across an old knitted blanket maybe
consider throwing it out if you want to
live now go and check out SCP 3032 and
then it was an angry spider for more
warnings about everyday objects that can
seem harmless at first but will quickly
turn deadly when you least expect it and
after that if you're in the market for a
piece of anomalous Furniture that's
still soft and cozy like the blanket but
nowhere near as dangerous then SCP 3832
surprise pillow fight might be just what
you need